...
. Google Cloud Platform on a
shoestring Budget
>> COLT MCANLIS: I love the
first person that claps.
A round of applause for this man
up
here, starting to clap for the
presenter.
Welcome to Day Two of Google
I/O. Everyone properly
caffeinated today? No? Okay.
Good to know.
I've got to tell you, when we
actually got this talk agreed
upon, they came to me. They
said, all right, you know, we
love
the title of your talk, GCP on a
shoestring k budget, helping
developers save on money, when
do you want to give the talk?
I said Day Three, 8:30 in the
morning.
No other possible opportunity
there. You want to know why?
Because the people who are
willing to go through two days
of standing in the sun and wake
up at 6:00 a.m.
to stand in the security line to
get in the seats by 8:30, they
care about saving money on
Google Cloud Platform, right?
Exactly.
So thank you for being here.
When we get a chance to talk to
a lot of developers around the
world, I find there's generally
two buckets of companies fall
into when you're talking about
saving costs.
The first one is the large
companies with established code
bases. They may have expected
workloads that come through
Google Cloud, but the
predominant conversations are,
if you make this change and this
change, you can save a lot of
money. And their response is
always along the lines of, well,
how much would that cost to
implement? We've got this legacy
code base.
You know, Bill over here is
really attached to that API, we
don't want to get rid of that.
Basically, any conversations,
they have an opportunity cost
tradeoff they have to make in
their head before they're
willing to make the changes to
save the money. Right?
On the other side, though, are
the hustlers, the rise and
grind, right? The startups.
The people trying to get the
costs as low as possible . They
know, that's the key to keeping
their business afloat right now.
And those are the people,
hopefully, that wake up so early
after two days of sunscreen and
dehydration to come to this sort
of talk. And that's who we're
talking about today.
All right? Google Cloud Platform
is huge. We have a ton of
different products. And quite
frankly, the 40 minutes they've
given me here, we don't have
time to go through all of them.
Number one, we're going to lay
foundation on the network and
show you how to save a little
bit of cost there. Then, we're
going to talk about ways to save
costs on compute, and then, a
couple of scenarios that
hopefully some of you fall into
and you'll have a better time
attaching to your business
model.
The most important thing you
need to know, nothing I'm
talking about today is secret.
None of this requires a
handshake or the right Google
badge. Every piece of data
you're seeing today is available
for you to go get right now.
Either using the Google Cloud
Platform
Pricing Calculator.
It's not an Illuminati style,
you can run analysis on
everything.
Serving data, this is where
we're going to start today.
Let's figure out, what does it
cost to serve one terabyte of
data from Google
Cloud Storage to your users?
Let's talk about serving data.
When you think about this, you
have two components involved.
First off, is storage, where
you're storing your data. And
second off, your network costs,
we're transferring the data.
Now, the cost for these are
dependent upon usage.
For example, Google Cloud
Storage, what you pay is a
function of where you're hosting
your data alongside of how much
you're hosting it.
If you're hosting in US Central
One, you're paying to store your
data, however, east, that
changes and a multi-region
bucket, that changes, as well.
On the networking side, it's
a tiered cost structure.
If you're under one terabyte,
you're paying a different tier.
And then, this also changes per
region, as well. So, for
example, if you're transferring
data from the Iowa location and
you're
in the first tier of under one,
paying about 12 cents a gig. We
have to point out something. And
this is not secret. There's a
whole tier of usage on Google
Cloud that's absolutely free.
That you get every single month.
You can use this stuff, no
one cares
about it, you're not going to
get charged For it, right?
It ranges mostly all of our
products, but most specifically,
worried ability the free tier
form. On the storage side, five
gigabytes of storage for free
each month each region.
If you've got 5 gigs in east and
5 in west, each one is free. On
the network side, we get about 1
gigabyte of egress, from North
American locations to other
destinations. And by the way,
you will see many caveats of
little stars during this. And
you'll also see a little labels
that says the price of today.
This is the cloud, prices
change.
And if you discover this
video in the future, you'll
undoubtedly find there's a
discrepancy in the prices.
Please make sure you check out
the documentation for the
latest.
So this is our free tier. Let's
talk about egress costs, then.
One terabyte, what would this
cost us? So to store it, we get
about one
terabyte of data, that's 10, 24
gigs, two cents per gig, about
$20 a month to store the data at
rest. Not too bad. On the
network side, though, things get
trickier.
We've got our one terabyte at 12
cents
per gig, about $122 a month,
total about $143.
Storing the data, transferring,
about $143. It isn't too bad, I
don't think. The truth is, most
of you don't send your users to
the cloud storage bucket. You
have a proxy, a front-end to hit
that this data's being routed
through. Let's look at what that
costs.
Basically, the same. So as
long as you're transferring
information in the same region
between a cloud storage bucket
and a proxy, compute engine
instance, it's free.
As long as it's in the same
region.
If they're coming from compute
or cloud storage. If you're
transferring all of your data
through a proxy, you're paying
the exact same price if it was
going through cloud storage
directly. You're paying for the
compute engine instance if it's
running. Or the app engine
instance. Basically, as long as
you're using a proxy, the basic
serving costs don't change.
Let's look at this from a
different way.
When we serve data to people,
one of the things we care about
is locality and latency.
We want to get our data as close
to users as possible. We also
want to do it as cheaply as
possible. Let's look at that
scenario. Let's say, we're
serving our data here,
we've got it in US West one and
we want to serve it in US East
One.
Price here is still the
same. $143. Doesn't matter where
the user's coming from. We have
the same cost at rest and the
same egress costs. But we want
to get that data closer to the
user.
What if we actually cloned that
data in
US East One and got it closer to
the user? Our egress is still 12
cents and cloud storage itself,
we're duplicating the data
between two buckets and paying
that extra two cents a gig. So
we're doubling our cost for
storage. And we also have this
extra one-cent per gig transfer
costs between them. We're moving
our data between regions.
Now, we have a cost incurred
with that. Cloned this data
between regions, we're looking
at $173.
Not ideal, but gets our data a
little bit closer. But truth is,
we might be thinking about this
the wrong way. We do have these
things in Google Cloud Storage,
regional buckets and
multiregional buckets.
Effectively, duplicate your data
between regions in an area so
you don't have to do this
cloning by yourself.
The trick, though, is
multiregional buckets cost more.
Let's take a look at that. If we
want to be go from cloud storage
to our users -- there's going to
be lots of weird acronyms and
terminology in this talk, it's
labeled intermediate. Hopefully,
we're moving together. 12 cents
a gig egress. We're paying 2.
6 cents per gig to store in a
multiregional bucket which puts
us at $26 a month instead of the
single region.
We're at about $149 there.
Not too much cost change. But
the difference here is that when
a user in US east one actually
asked for
this asset, Google handles the
duplication on your behalf and
you don't have to clone it
yourself.
Basically, just saved an extra
$30 by using a multiregional
bucket per month instead of
cloning it ourselves.
Sounds good. We've reduced our
cost inside the regional US.
What if we want to go
international. We want to serve
this data to someone in Europe,
right? Well, let's take a look
at cloning there, as well. We
have our clone data in a US
multiregion and EU multiregion.
We're duplicating our costs. We
have the same amount of cost
egress
for US -- the EU multiregion,
which is selected For these
numbers. However, now because
we're transferring data between
multiregions in different areas,
we're actually at 12 cents per
gig transfer.
So we actually get a little
pricier there. $286 is the
result of this. If you're trying
to get your data to users in a
different area using the
multiregion, it's actually
really expensive. Let's rethink
this here.
The goal, again, we're
shoestring, right? We want to
make this as cheap as possible.
We want to get data from the
cheapest
bucket we can store in to the
farthest away user as fast as
possible as cheap as possible.
We have this, it's the CDM.
We've been working with these.
Let's figure out what the cost
is of that.
We've got our standard regional,
about 2 cents a gig. For CDNs,
two costs to be aware of. We
have a fill cost and an egress
cost. To fill data into the
cache, you're looking at about 4
cents per gig to get it into the
CDN. That's worldwide. Doesn't
matter where you're going. If
you have data here and someone
in
Nairobi asks for your asset --
Now, egress from the CDN is only
8 cents per gig. When you
combine these two together, four
cents and eight cents, 12 cents
per gig, which is your standard
egress rate.
However, this is assuming a
one-to-one ratio, if you're
pushing a terabyte, you're going
to end up at
about $143 to get the asset as
close to every user in the world
without lifting a finger except
making sure your cache headers
are turned on properly.
In reality, this isn't how
things work out. Typically, the
amount of cache fill versus
cache serve are different.
Where 20% of your data is filled
into the cache and 80% is served
out, you
actually only end up closer to
about $91. As long as that ratio
is on the serving side instead
of the filling side, you're
going to have a lot cheaper
representation and setup. You're
going to get to the shoestring
value you want.
In general here, if we're
looking to
serve a terabyte of data, the
cheapest thing we can do is
simply to set your caching
headers. Any other tricks or any
other smartness you're trying to
do is going to blow that up,
right? It's going to make things
more expensive. Find the
cheapest bucket that's as close
to you as you can tolerate, and
let Google's point of presence
network handle the rest.
Let's talk about compute. So
Google Cloud Platform has a lot
of compute offerings. Today,
we're going to talk about three
of them.
Google Compute Engine, our
standard VMs that run in the
cloud.
Second is Google Cloud
Functions, innovation based.
And Google App Engine. And for
the sake of this talk, I'm
going to ignore things like GKE
and GAE Flex, they tend to price
themselves closer to what GCE
is. But for the sake of this
40-minute talk, we don't have to
go into the nuances. It's weird.
I'm going to ignore those,
and we're going to focus on
these three.
By cost, GCE is variable on
config, depending on the
configuration is how much you're
going to pay. The beefier the
machine and the configuration,
the more you're going to have to
pay there. Cloud Functions,
though, is different. About 40
cents per million calls that you
make to it.
And then, an additional cost,
gigabyte second and gigahertz
second. And there's a breakdown
here.
And of course, App Engine is
going to
be 5 cents to 30 cents depending
on your config. This is the
default cost you have here.
On the other side, we have our
free tiers. Here's where things
get cool. In a compute engine,
if you're using an F1
microconfiguration, it's free
the whole month. No cost to you.
Free instance, sitting in
the cloud, doing your bidding as
much as you'd like it, all free.
On GCF, you've got about 2
million innovocations a month.
And on App Engines, 21 instance
hours a
day, and nine instance hours a
day for a B1 instance. I know
there's more than -- less than
28 hours in a day. That gives
you a little bit of wiggle room
in case it spins up in an F1.
Basically, when you look at GAE
F1, you kind of get free compute
as long as
you're under a certain strata of
usage.
With this in mind, let's look at
an always on cost.
You want to run a box for an
entire month, what does that
cost you?
Months have different days. I'm
going to assume 730 hours of
consistent run time.
When you bump up to an N1
standard one because you want a
little more performance, you
start paying $24 a
month and $194 for an 8-core
machine.
This is on the Cloud Pricing
Page, and
this is after 30% sustained
usage account.
We can't just say, consistently
running. So what I've done here
is I'm making the assumption
that you're getting one
invocation to your cloud
function service every second
for the entire month. Got about
2.6 million innovations that's
going on there.
For this, it's about $3.
51 to basically have a GCF
function running every second
for an entire month.
On App Engine, you end up in the
F1 config, it's free, don't have
to change anything there.
However, if that second F1
instance actually spins up, you
get a little spike in your
workload or all of a
sudden you're the top of hacker
dues for some reason, you're
going to pay $36 for that second
instance to come on board.
Of course, when you move up to
an F2 or F4, you get the $73.
Across the board here, you can
see in
GCE and GAE, as you get a
stronger machine. Of course, the
costs go up. While GCF is
instance-based.
Here's the interesting thing,
those are the basic costs.
Compute engine is the most VER
versatile thing you have. It's
also the most expensive for what
you're using. If we could figure
how to make that cost effective
as our other services without
the same limitations.
If we wanted to run our code
on GCF,
each function invocation has a
nine-minute time-out.
On App Engine, you have a
60-second on request, but if you
push that off to a task later,
you end up with the same
nine-minute time-out.
Our goal is to make GCE as cheap
as our other alternatives. We
can do this.
First off, let's take a look
at the GCE discounts. These are
the things that you don't have
to lift any fingers to do to
actually turn this stuff on.
First off is sustained use. What
we'll do is analyze your usage.
And if you have a sustained
usage, you're always on for a
certain amount of time, we'll
give you a default discount for
running your instance with
consistency across the entire
month.
If you're willing to make a
phone call to our sales team and
can actually commit to usage,
specific usage and say I'm going
to run, at least, 2,000 hours
this month or 730 hours this
month, doesn't matter what
configuration you're using and
you don't have predefinition of
specific upfront fees or
whatever, you can actually get
up to a 56% discount by just
making a phone call to talk to
sales.
If you're a startup and
seeing more usage and need that
dedicated resource and you know
you're going to have one or
two instances in a dedicated --
it's actually pretty huge. And
right sizing. What will happen
is Google Cloud Platform will
actually analyze the usage of
the GC instances and look at how
you're using them and actually
tell you
whether or not you're
overprovisioned or
underprovisioned.
And you'll see a little icon on
the home page that says if you
click here, we'll reconfigure
and save you money every month.
Likewise, it'll say you're using
this pretty hard. If you click
here, we'll beef up your machine
so your users get lower latency.
TV it's a fun button you can
click, the deployment happens
behind the scenes. This is
automatic stuff.
However, something a little bit
more drastic in terms of saving
that does require a little bit
of work on your part is
preemptive. Means that the
scheduler is allowed to kill
your instance when we need the
resources in Google Cloud. Now,
that may sound really scary. But
here's the fun part, it'll alert
your instance before it's about
to get killed.
So it'll send you a message and
your instance will say, hey, I'm
about to terminate you, you have
30 seconds to
back up data to a persistent
resource.
And it'll start your instance
back up later and you can fetch
that data and continue working
on. Right? So if you allow us to
kill your instance when we need
the time, we actually give you a
substantial discount. If you're
running an N1 standard that's
preemptive, instead of the $24 a
month, you get about $7 a month.
For the same instance and all
you have to do is write the code
so you can lay
over those sort of terminations
after time.
You can put a load balancer in
front of that.
If you need Scalable Compute and
the ability to allow the things
to die but you've got so much
load coming in, one of them
going down, another one might
have to spin up. Putting a load
balancer in front of the
instances means you're only
paying about $7 a month per
instance you're actually
running.
If we can get this a little
bit
cheaper, in fact, if we use a
microinstance, instead. We can
get it down to $2.96 a month.
Because of the fact that we have
our load balancer and because of
the fact
that we've reengineered our code
to make sure it can be false
tolerant when it's killed, we
have a massively Scalable
compute resource that can handle
itself getting kicked over.
If you've got large amounts of
work loads or individual things,
processing files, you know,
something can pick up processing
50% where something else left
off, this is an extremely cheap
solution for you. Probably as
cheap as I was able to find in
my research.
So in general, if you want
to reduce your compute cost,
you've got a couple of things to
do.
Distribute workloads that are
based on
invocations to either app engine
or cloud functions. Those are
going to be the cheapest
situations where you can put
your code and have them run. If
you need something long running,
then leave it back on compute
engine, otherwise, try to push
as much as you can to the
resources. That's the cheapest
you can get.
do. Distribute workloads that
are based on invocations to
either app engine or cloud
functions. Those are going to be
the cheapest situations where
you can put your code and have
them run. If you need something
long running, then leave it back
on compute engine, otherwise,
try to push as much as you can
to the resources. That's the
cheapest you can get.
Likewise, make that phone
call to sales. Let them know
that you can commit to a
sustained use and get that
discount. That's going to be
huge for the work jobs you need
running consistently on compute
engine. Likewise, if you have
Scalable needs, a
load balancer plus a
micro-preemptive
instance, it's the highest
flexibility, lowest cost
scenario you can be in. Having a
bunch of little spiders doing
your work for you is just as
effective
as one doing it for the same
price.
We've laid the groundwork to
look at the big picture.
Now, let's talk about some
scenarios.
Personal privacy matters online,
right?
We all care about that. But
sometimes, I don't like paying a
subscription to some other as
far as to, you know, handle a
VPN service. So how cheap can we
build our own personal VPN
service on Google Cloud. PVR to
be clear here, I know that
personal security online is a
very hectic area right now. And
there's lots of back and forth.
So to be clear, I'm not going to
talk about why you need a VPN,
the softwares and libraries you
can use, having your own versus
part of a cluster. I'm not going
to talk about anything that PR
or legal would raise an eyebrow
about.
But I'm going to talk about how
you can run for as cheap as
possible. Right?
So with this, we have two
components, compute and network,
pretty easy. How a VPN generally
works is you have your client
that connects to some compute
engine instance that's running
your VPN, there's a socket
connection between the two,
exchanging encrypted data and
the compute or the proxy going
out into the fantastic internet
and do the fetching for you.
This is a high-level
approximation if there's
security engineers in the room,
I apologize for generalizing
that to the point that I can fit
on the slide.
Let's look at the free tier
here, how cheap could we make
this? If we use our instance as
an F1 micro, we can get that for
free.
And as long as our usage is
about less than one gig, we know
that we can get that for free,
as well. Right? If our usage is
less than one gig, we
can get a VPN we can use
whenever we
want every single month using
Google Cloud Platform. And you
only start to pay when you go
over the free gig.
If you're using this for WI-FI
hot spots around the world,
you're getting this whole thing
for free. No big deal.
Here's one of the problems, if
you're using a preemptive
version of that, you have a
problem you need to know where
to connect to. And every time
you reboot that VM, you have a
new IP.
The good news on Google
Platform, you can reserve a
static IP address. And as long
as it's assigned and being used,
it's free for you. You can go
in, create your instance,
let it run, get a static
reserved IP address that you can
use from your personal devices
that stick around waiting for
you and you don't pay anything,
right?
So, again, we can run a personal
VPN for a static IP for nothing
each month. And again, if you
eclipse the one gig free tier,
that's when you start paying.
Let's talk about two specific
scenarios. What if you want
better bandwidth? What if you
want this VPN because you need
to stream a video from specific
location. The important thing to
understand is the throughput for
a GCE instance changes based
upon the core count. It's capped
at the core count.
So the more cores you have,
you can see here that on the
side there at the 64 and 32
cores, the more cores you
have, the higher the throughput.
This is where people get caught
up.
You'll notice, that the --
moving up
from the F1 micro, the next
available option is the small.
However, you notice because of
the number of core count is the
same, we actually don't get any
better bandwidth by moving to
there, even though it's only $14
a month.
Moving on to the next one, the
first stage where you get
bandwidth increase is the N1
standard.
If you're moving up and trying
to get bandwidth, you have to
start paying $24 a month.
You have to deal when you're in
the middle of a session.
Let's talk about traveling.
A lot of us are international no
mads, we travel, go to
conferences, customers whatnot.
It would be nice if we have our
VPN
follow
us so actually, put together a
little hack for this that I
wanted to share with everybody.
So it turns out that you can,
actually,
run a Google Compute engine
APIs. I wrote a little web
location that I host.
When I load it while I'm
TRALing, it'll figure out my
location is and it'll figure out
the closest zone that I can run
an F1 instance.
I can basically click a single
button and create the new as
close as possible no matter
where I am in the world.
For free, I'm not doing more
than 2 million invocations a
month. If you want to give
people in the family using your
VPN and maybe charge them $10 a
month, this might be a nice
racket to play at Thanksgiving.
Anybody word press experts?
Still, no caffeine in the house.
I like that, closer to 9:00 a.m.
and everyone's still sleeping.
This is good.
So Word Press is a large and
unwieldy beast.
When you, actually, Google for
Word Press Google Cloud
Platform, the first thing you're
introduced to is a page for
our Google Cloud launcher with
the preconfig operations that
allow you to deploy to your
Google Cloud account and get up
and start moving, right? You can
click any of these and they have
a bunch of configurations of how
you want it all set up.
However, the default setup is
actualliless than ideal from an
expense perspective.
They are going to be set up with
$24 a month. You're paying from
the egress out there.
What if you're using the
simplest Word Press site
possible? And you're using a
single instance, right? You
don't have that number, you
know, that many number of users.
Well, you can use the F1
microfor this instead, which is
free, per month.
And
-- if you're a brand new startup
and your friends are, like, hey,
it's $10, sign up.
And you're still living on ramen
along with 40 other people, this
saves you that $10 a month to
buy more ramen. Yay. But the
question we have, then, is the
concept
that we're free as long as we're
under the free tier. What is the
cost before we eclipse that,
right?
Our default word press site that
you
deploy on App Engine is about
272,000
per visitor, about 3,800
visitors a month before you have
to start paying.
This is a number of startups for
the hustle and flow type people.
Knowing how many visitors you
can take
before you have to start paying
money. And, of course, we could
go into a massive diatribe about
how to compress your headers and
serve that data. That's a
different talk.
Right now, just talking about
the fundamental. If we're under
4,000 users a month, we
should be okay in and in the
free tier. If you turn on
caching headers, increase this
number significantly because the
more users you have, doesn't
come out of the main bucket,
comes out of a different bucket,
you get a lot more users to hit
your information.
But what if you end up on
the top of hacker news,
suddenly, and you need to start
scaling up and down. Putting the
load balancer between the CDN
actually lets you do this. You
end up with the same egress,
right? 8 cents per gig outbound
and same fill. And we can
actually end up with the F1
micro. The problem now we have
is because we have a number of
instances instead of a single
one.
You need a persistent my SQL
instance for the compute
instances.
Now, unfortunately, as of today,
I
could not find a way to get a
free tier setup with the SQL
instance. That's going to be
around $29 a month.
If you're above the 4,000 user
mark and expecting scaling, the
minimum cost you'll end up
paying around $29. Just to make
sure that cloud SQL instance is
sitting around.
It's worth noting, there's a
plug-in for App Engine.
You can actually run it on an F1
micro
instance or Word Press and get
that down to about zero dollars
a month,
unfortunately, you need the back
end at about $29 a month, as
well. Something to think about.
In general, if you're doing Word
Press, there's three strata to
think about to ensure you're
thinking about your shoestring
style budget.
Under 4,000 visitors, use an F1
micro, turn on the CDN and
you'll get the whole thing for
free. That's fantastic.
If you're above 4,000 visitors,
then you need to start thinking
about stringing together compute
engine plus
the load balancer, plus the CDN
and the SQL option. You have
enough users there, you need to
start making sure you're doing
things properly. However, I've
got to tell you there is a
number of hosted word press
companies
that have their back ends built
on Google Cloud Platform that do
offer you a subscription-based
service.
Paying $4 a month, they'll deal
with all of the scaleability,
they'll deal with all of the
security updates, they'll make
sure everything's running in the
background. You don't have to
lift a finger and might be a
cheaper option to fall into
that bucket if you're above
4,000 visitors. That might be
something to look into.
Final topic for the day.
Video content side on the
shoestring
bucket budget.
What would it take to look at an
education website? You have
students that log in, data
they want to look at, watch
videos, take some tests. Maybe a
sports site that's streaming all
of your high school sports games
and you've got a lot of video to
transfer.
Some combination of rich
multimedia and rich website
presence. So with a standard
layout here, you would probably
have to store that video data in
Google Cloud Storage, right? And
serve that to the user so you
can get streaming capability.
You don't want that going to a
proxy. You want straight to the
source there.
On the website side, maybe a
Word Press instance. It's got
some connection to relational
database so it can keep track of
who the users are and any other
key words that you need. And of
course, your standard load
balancing and CDN in front of
that, scale up, scale down and
make sure that your data is
consistently sent to users
around the world.
This gets pretty pricey,
unfortunately, right? You're
looking at $24 for the compute
engines per instance a month,
looking at $29 for the cloud
instance, you've got
your fill and egress costs
. As of today, this can change
in the future, internet, if
you're watching this sometime in
the future.
As of today, the Cloud CDN,
that's coming from Google Cloud
Storage does
not cache 206 responses from a
header. 206 responses are used
for streaming video, which
means, as you're streaming
video, it's not going through
the cache, right?
So we have to be very cautious
of
this. Not really ideal. This
whole thing can get pretty
costly. But there actually is a
solution if you're willing to
make a couple of changes. We can
get this almost down to free
instead of all of this cost.
If you're willing to make some
changes, leave your CDN in
place.
Minimize all your complexity
down to something it can use a
template for.
Make an invocation based, you
don't need to do that much on
the back end. And as long as
you're under 2 million page
views an month, you can
basically get that entire
serving process for free, which
is pretty nice.
Likewise, instead of using Cloud
SQL,
use Data Store.
Data Store will still give you
the performance you need. And it
has its own free tier.
If you're under one gigabyte of
stored
data and doing less than 500,000
reads, you pay nothing.
This is in the range of a
MOOK-style startup. Yo don't
have all of the visitors you
need. And even the successful
ones are probably not doing
500,000 per month. And a
gigabyte of relational data is a
lot in that scenario.
We can get our entire website
serving and backend storage for
zero dollars.
The problem, though, is what
do we do about the video
content? There's no other real
place to store
this in Google Storage because
206 responses. My only solution
here, a little bit of a hack,
store all of your video in
YouTube.
Upload your video to
YouTube, leave it as unlisted,
right? And basically, when
you're streaming
your embedded URLs down to your
user, make it so they can't
figure out where your videos
are. If you can get it this way,
you get the entire video
production platform for free.
A lot of chuckles. Yeah,
this slide is very contentious
internally. We had a lot of
talks. We mad a lot of talks
internally.
About whether or not that last
little animation should be in
this talk at all. Yeah. So with
that, I want to thank you for
your time today. I want to thank
you for being the hustlers and
the grinders working on your
costs every single day. I want
to thank you for waking up this
early to hear another bald man
rant at you.
Most importantly, if you care
about costs, performances, I've
got to encourage you to check
out the YouTube channel for
Google Cloud Platform. We have a
ton of amazing people working
working on amazing content to
increase scaleability and get
your Cloud Application to where
you want it as cheap as
possible.
With that, thank you, enjoy your
last day of Google I/O. Thank
you very much.
What's New in Android Apostrophe
for
Chrome OS
>> SHAHID HUSSAIN: Hi, everyone.
My name is Shahid. And welcome
to all of you to our
session on developing Android
Apps on Chrome OS. We talked
about this last year at I/O, and
if you saw that talk, today's
talk is a continuation. When
you're talking about the basics
briefly, and talking about how
we've worked with a number of
you over the past year.
And as well as sharing a
number of new features we'd love
to tell you about. So first of
all, let's talk about why this
matters.
So we've talked previously about
the
success of Chromebooks within
the education space where we
outsell every other device
combined. But Google's been
doubling down on Chrome OS.
That's helped drive demand in
the consumer space, too.
So much so that in Q4 last year,
17% of
notebooks sold in the US were
Chromebooks.
[ Applause ]
Why does this matter to you?
Android developers?
The headline here is Android
apps work on Chrome OS. How does
that happen?
It works by the Android
framework running inside a
container that sits on top of
the base of Chrome OS, and the
full Play Store is available. So
your app is probably already
running on Chrome OS.
Now, ultimately, what we care
about is a good user experience.
Part of that is the operating
system
itself, and part of that is the
apps it runs. And we've been
investing heavily on improving
the product. Those of you who
have used it over the past year,
have seen all of that and system
updates.
And many of you who are
developing apps, we've been
working with to ensure that
you're ensuring that the apps
work really well on Chrome OS.
Adobe,
Sony and EA have included
Chromebook operations into the
latest updates in the Play
Store.
And that's opening up different
kinds of usage and revenue.
May Allen told us pixelbook
users
are spending 4 times more time
in Evernote than an app user.
And Andrew and David told us
that Chromebooks have made up
21% of their revenue over the
last 30 days.
So first of all, to begin, we're
quickly going to vie some
basics.
Ensuring that an app works well
on Chrome OS comes down to four
key
differences
May Allen told us pixelbook
users are spending 4 times more
time in Evernote than an app
user. And Andrew and David told
us that Chromebooks have made up
21% of their revenue over the
last 30 days.
So first of all, to begin, we're
quickly going to vie some
basics. Ensuring that an app
works well on Chrome OS comes
down to four key differences
between Chromebooks and phones.
Wider screens, default
landscape, window management and
different primary input devices.
Keyboard, pointer, stylus.
First, why the screens?
Chromebook screens are bigger
from 10.
1 inch on the smaller side to
15-inch on our larger units.
Apps need to work well and
respond appropriately to resize
events.
For example,
the app is resized to be wider.
Second, default landscape, as a
default landscape device, apps
need to have a really great
landscape experience.
And for example, pocket cast
pins open the menu and arranges
items in a grid so they can fill
the space available rather than
listing items out with white
space to the right.
Third, multiwindow.
Chrome OS is a multi-window
desktop environment. The latest
versions on the play store and
now resizable. So users can work
better with these inside our
environment.
And finally, maybe the most
important, keyboard and mouse
inputs. When a user pulls out a
laptop and uses it, the keyboard
and touch pad are closer to the
user so they gravitate towards
them as the primary inputs.
Built keyboard accelerators so
users can get around faster
inside the interface. And that's
true for games.
War Robots built keyboard
controls into the game.
It uses a special manifest flag
to get inputs directly from
Chrome OS and enables standard
gaming controls.
So these are just a few of the
app teams who are now building
and testing
their apps for Chrome OS and a
huge, huge thank you to
everyone, many of you are here
in the audience, that we've
worked with.
We're always looking for
apps that work really, really
great on Chrome OS so we can
show them off.
And we want your app to be one
of them. Now, to talk about some
of the latest
improvements in Chrome OS for
Android
app developments, I'd like to
hand off to Stefan. Please
welcome, Stefan.
[ Applause ]
>> STEFAN KUHNE: Morning,
everyone.
I'm glad you could all join for
today's talk. And I'm here to
talk about, well, all
of our latest news what we have
done and what you can do to
improve the
application even more for the
desktop environment.
What is new?
So that is one of the things
which is
mostly important for the user.
And we hope that -- and last of
it, best practices.
So when you're following these
practices, you will have a
better chance.
So what's new? Let's see, first
off, we have improved our tablet
mode. Why did we do that?
Because we have now also a
tablet only device. Well, and
what do we change? Well, there
are smooth animations. We have
removed the caption bar. I means
the window control bar, and the
controls from the caption
bar, they've moved to the shelf.
And all windows are
automatically started full
screen. So which is, of course,
experience what you expect on
the tablet.
So next thing is split screen.
We havethat? Because we have now
also a tablet only device. Well,
and what do we change? Well,
there are smooth animations. We
have removed the caption bar. I
means the window control bar,
and the controls from the
caption bar, they've moved to
the shelf. And all windows are
automatically started full
screen. So which is, of course,
experience what you expect on
the tablet.
So next thing is split
screen. We have a split screen,
you know that, of course, on
phones, but now on a big
tablet or bigger screen, it
makes more sense.
It might be a Chrome window,
might be an Android window.
The only thing, at the moment,
you will not be able to be able
to figure out you're running in
split screen. The next thing is,
picture in picture.
So it's a full specification
according to Android O, and
it'll come in soon. And you can
resize the window, place it in
multiple locations and it'll be
fairly similar to the one which
we are using for web
applications, as well.
So we have also added the
Android keyboard so you can
essentially replace,
now, coming soon.
The Chrome OS keyboard was an
Android keyboard, which makes a
lot of people happy.
Notifications -- they're looking
much
more like. Color scheming should
be much more integrated. Instead
of swiping -- everything is
much more integrated into the
Chrome OS style in itself.
And, yeah. Pro audio.
We have, actually, edit since
M65, the beginning of this year.
It's essentially, like, every
six weeks
we have a new release cycle, and
M65 is out.
And our pixelbook.
And soon, we will also have
multichannel audio, USB audio,
multichannel USB audio and this
is all coming later this year.
And with that, you have actually
seen when you were coming in
someone playing music here. He
was, actually, using a
pixelbook. And to show you a
little bit more about
that, I want to
invite the founder of algorithm
to show how this actually works.
(Music playing)
[ Applause ]
>> STEFAN KUHNE: Thank you.
You've seen how everything was
realtime, sync NIZedtime
synchronized with the device.
Syncs what you can do in order
to make your life well, to make
life on a desktop better.
Well, I think I had that
already last year, but we have,
of course, a follow-up on that
one. So first off, this is
something which is something
everybody knows from everyday
business, right? Menu
accelerators, they're not
something special, right?
But if you were using the
toolkit of the past, it was,
actually, from A.
I think it was, like, angel
cake. So really ancient. This
was small and they had to,
actually, fit everything on
there.
And it looked ugly, it was not
meant to be prime time. So we
have actually changed the
library to make this much, much
easier for you to actually get
these kind of things in. And so,
all you have to do is go into
your layout XML.
In your menu, put into the item
itself, and then, the shortcut
means the character and modifier
keys.
And you're ready to go. Well,
not entirely.
You have to actually pull, then,
the -- what was it, again? Set
clarity mode to true so that
you're
actually getting alphanumeric
characters.
This is really old, but it's
still there. Shelf integration,
that is something, like, if you
want to do something inside the
shelf, you want to change your
icon,
like, for example, opening a
document or whatnot and change
the shape of the icon itself and
display, then, the document
you've opened, you can do that
with this set task description.
Very simple and very
effective.
Next thing is, if you want to
combine
multiple items inside the shelf
into one
menu item, you can actually put,
then,
extra, you put, then, the shelf
shortcut to it and you take,
then, any kind of string for a
kind of modifier that you know
and actually use it for all of
the items you want to put into
the same thing.
App shortcuts are coming.
This is something which is
coming soon. We will support
them very soon, as well.
Essentially, you can actually
have actions and any kind of
short things which you want to
do in order to get the user fast
access to things.
The big button.
Well, I think many of you since
you are doing something for our
Chrome OS, have already seen
there's a back button up in the
window control bar.
Well you have also a Back
Button. And two on top of each
other looks pretty crappy.
Therefore, by adding the special
effect, you can get rid of it.
It makes it nicer and that
helps.
But there's one other thing,
and this is even more important.
If you're on a desktop and
pressing backspace or escape and
your window suddenly disappears,
something have is very
unexpected as a user, please
don't do that.
If you can do it, please what
you should do is actually check
if your activity is at the
bottom -- at the root of the
stack.
And if it is and you know your
window, please don't close your
window. It's really unexpected
and disturbing all of the work
is suddenly gone.
Lifetime management. We are
getting a lot of requests from
users which said, well, you know
what, my application isn't
running multitasking. Why is it
not multitasking? Well, the
thing is, I have this game I'm
playing and I'm also checking my
new status.
My news status isn't updating
while I'm playing.
Well, there are three states,
running, post and stopped.
Running and paused means you are
visible on the screen.
Not that you should actually
drop everything and stop that
when you're getting a pause, no,
you can continue to
run unless you are high --
whatever
game, when you need realtime
action and whatnot where you
want to really pause. In most
cases you really want to
continue running.
Please do this and you make
a lot of users much, much
happier. Next thing, sharing
data. Well, I said already
earlier that we have plenty of
windows on our desktop, right?
So there are all kinds of Chrome
OS window and whatnot.
If you don't specify drag drop
local, it will not be dropped on
another location. This is only
for you. In order to allow other
applications to
actually get your data, specify
this.
And if you are actually getting
some
data from someone also, check
out what you're getting.
If you're blind
ly -- if you're looking at the
clipboard, it's exactly the same
thing. You definitely want to
have, of course,
all of the richness of whatever
is being copied and pasted, as
well.
So with that, resizing. I
was talking last year about
resizing that it's a big
problem, right?
Resizing looks pretty clunky on
Android when you're doing this.
This is an application which is
written for material design 2.
0definitely want to have, of
course, all of the richness of
whatever is being copied and
pasted, as well.
So with that, resizing. I was
talking last year about resizing
that it's a big problem, right?
Resizing looks pretty clunky on
Android when you're doing this.
This is an application which is
written for material design 2.0.
And it looks nice on a phone,
see? This looks, actually,
pretty nice.
So when you are doing -- when
you're following the design
study from material
design, coming up with this
thing. See, there's more
information.
You can actually see more things
and they are revealing more
stuff.
So with that, let me show you
my notebook.
So there's the application.
And you can resize it.
And you can see, WHOOIM resizing
it, more and more data is coming
into play.
And more. That, of course, is
the wrong guy.
And there we go. And you see
that more and more data is
coming in.
This is all dynamically
happening
while resizing it, more and more
data is coming into play. And
more. That, of course, is the
wrong guy. And there we go. And
you see that more and more data
is coming in. This is all
dynamically happening.
First off, good news, the
demo is online, you can download
it, test it out yourself.
It's on GitHub: And there's an
excellent code lab, which is
showing more.
So also doing animations
while you're transforming from
one layout into another.
You should check out the CodeLab
for sure.
How is it being done? You need a
constrained layout. It's like a
blueprint essentially getting
the layouts into some kind of
order.
When to use which one.
Every one of these layouts need
to have new IO elements.
If you want to show it, you hide
-- it's still in the layout
itself. So by doing this. And on
create, you'll create the
transition you want to use when
you want
to transition from B one to the
other.
And the layout handler, you will
be
able
to -- essentially, like, giving
the
control to
the -- to the -- sorry, giving
the
control to our layout
, which is in the transition
itself.
Inside the activity, you have to
add the on configuration change
which is usually being called
when something changes like the
keyboard is connected to the
screen or anything like that.
And from there, you essentially
are calling the constraint
changed layout handler is to let
him know what the size is.
And with that, you are done.
If you want to try it out,
try the code lab to get this
done.
What does zero latency ink mean?
There is a lag between drawing
something or using the pen and
seeing
something on the device itself.
Where is it coming from?
You have to do a drawing and
multiple buffering because you
have to pass
everything to the come POZ or
the -- and it's going to the end
of the
pipeline, which might be four
images or whatnot.
So in total, you're coming out
to 100 milliseconds of delay,
which is very, very noticeable.
The ideal thing is, of course,
you simply remove all of the
compositing.
Now you're down to roughly two
frames.
The prediction logic to it,
well, then, we are really at
pretty much zero.
Which is showing the whole thing
in action.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
>> SHAHID HUSSAIN: Hi,
everyone. Let's see.
Whoops.
Can you see what I've got up
there? So I drew some spiderman,
that's
typically what I'm known for at
Marvel, but I also drew Thanos.
Anybody see Infinity War yet? I
did, too.
I like you can rotate, draw at
any angle. You can also do
layers.
This is infinite painter, by the
way.
What I've done, drawn Spidey
ahead of time. And I'm going to
ink on top of him
using some the inking tools.
I've got to change my
color -- I'm from a school of
thought
where Spiderman should have
expressive eyes, I'm glad they
did that in the movies.
Some people don't like to do the
webbing, but I do.
It's worth it in the end.
And then, of course, you can
add color, as well. I put in a
layer already.
With a red base and I'm going to
add some shadow to it.
One of the other features I like
about this, you can double tap
to reset it and then, if you
hold and long press, it'll flip
it.
So I'm always flipping things,
if I can because it gives you a
fresh perspective.
Of course, there's all kinds
of drawing tools that you can
use.
Some are
What I did was clipped the
shadow layer to the layer
beneath it, which means that
everything I do on this layer
will be bounded by the layer
below it.
One way to save time
. Of course, the other nice
thing about the stylus, it has
tilt.
In this case, I made tilt.
Depending on which way I hold
the pen, it will give me a thick
or thin line.
I could do this all day.
I usually do.
Usually, there aren't this many
people watching while I'm
drawing.
Y'all are lucky I'm even wearing
pants.
Let's finish it off with Spidey
sense because Thanos is nearby.
There we go. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> STEFAN KUHNE: If you want
access to it, there's a QR code,
please grab it.
And sign up for our release. So
you will be added to the release
as soon as we are giving you
access to it.
You can see the code and it
might change a little bit.
So multidisk player. You have an
internal screen and external
screen. But if you're really
creative, you have a pixelbook,
you might get up to seven
screens. I'm not entirely sure.
I've heard that is possible.
Anyways, but the thing is,
like, what does it mean for you?
Actually, it means a lot. Many
applications are doing stupid
things. Sorry, you are not that.
Hey, I want the addition play
information for ID zero, it's a
default.
It's not the default, what
is the default disk player. You
don't know that, right?
So therefore, we have, actually,
if
you are pre-O, we are thinking
you're a
non-disk player application.
Essentially, zero is, like, a
vitriol display. And the API is
clear, exactly like it should
be, but you get this kind of
special display so you're
working fine.
If on the other hand, something
after O or O, then you will
actually get a different
treatment. In that case, you
will get the real IDs, the
display IDs. You should be
careful what you are doing.
So, yeah, one additional thing
is if
you are, actually, running an
application, you have the launch
display ID as a function cord.
You should definitely use the
size of the window.
The display metrics from that.
That is working perfectly for
you. And if you wanted to see
any kind of changes, for
example, move to a different
display or something, then look
at configuration change to see
the kind of changes.
And if you want to,
actually, position yourself,
think also about set launch
display ID. If you do not want
to get to the same screen while
your current application is on.
What you shouldn't do is you
shouldn't really assume anything
without using your context. If
you're using any kind of display
ID, I mean, trying to get the
default display, you will get
something, which is most
certainly wrong.
So and also, what was that?
Yeah, don't make any assumptions
that
you are on the built-in display,
because that is wrong, as well.
And last but not least,
don't assume that you're always
running from the same display.
So presentation API, we're being
asked to get this to you. We are
getting that very, very soon.
And it is -- well, actually, I
think pretty much by now, it
should be there.
You can alternatively also use
set
launch display ID and set
launch, which will do the same
thing.
3D gaming.
We have Vulkan support.
It was shipping already -- it
was the shipping the beginning
of this year, shipping around
now. And older architectures are
on the way.
So much faster and so on. So
when you're building your own
game, so there are a few things
what you should take care of.
First off, you should always use
the latest version of the
framework. If you're using Unity
and whatnot, they are fixing
their stuff. Window size changes
and input changing a little bit.
They will actually fix that for
you. So please, use the latest
one because otherwise your
application will fail and you're
trying to be resized.
So the next thing is also use 64
bit or native code, as well.
Don't use only ARM because it
is, of course, a little bit
slower especially on the
high-end devices.
So when you're running a game.
Application quality control
might actually be bad for you.
Depending on what you're doing.
So if, for example, multiple
surfaces and whatnot and trying
to squeeze out the latest thing.
And if you're running into a
state
where you're using buffering
because
you're composite on the desktop,
your quality control might
actually do something negative
to your quality and you get some
kind of really good behavior.
So therefore, try it out on
Chromebooks before you release
it. That will be really awesome.
And, yeah, if you're using a lot
of
layers, like a lot of surface
use and whatnot, you might also
fall out of this and then your
quality might actually drop.
If you can do everything in
the single layer, please try to
do that instead.
And always be aware that your
window size might change at any
point in time. And, of course,
since users, for example,
minimizing you, you might
actually lose your state and/or
if the window is getting
resized, the state might
actually be lost.
So please save your state. Best
practices. As I said earlier, we
are trying to
work with Play Store to surface
applications that are good for
the Chrome OS environment.
Therefore, if you are doing
everything
which we ask for, you will get a
better rating. Target SDK bigger
than 26, that is definitely
something good.
Implement keyboard mouse
navigation, that is a good
thing. UI elements when you're
resizing, they
should always be inside the
screen
. When you're doing resizing,
definitely try to think about
landscape and portrait. Both
orientations are very important.
Make good use of a lot of space.
Because you have a lot of space.
So use it. I showed you how
to.
Use architectural components
whenever
possible to save your state.
Be fluid and please don't crash.
Check out that you are not
crashing.
And with that, I'm passing it on
to
Emelie who is talking about the
great tools we have for you.
>> EMILIE ROBERTS: Thank you.
There's so many exciting new
things for
Android applications on Chrome
OS. And I'm honored to present
to you three new amazing
developer tools to help
optimizing your application for
Chrome OS faster and easier.
The first one, you've all been
very patient, thank you for your
patience and a big thank you to
the engineering team for making
this happen. And doing it right.
In Android Studio, pleased to
present
the Chrome OS emulator.
[ Applause ]
So right in Android Studio, a
full Chrome OS image, test out
the user flow for Chrome OS and
test and optimize your app for
Android, Android application
right in Chrome OS, which is
awesome.
If any of you have ever made an
Android application. Some of you
did, if you do, you'll know
there's nothing like testing on
a real device.
Especially, a form factor
like this where the user will be
flipping it, rotating it,
tossing it on the bed,
keyboard input, mini
controllers, stylus input. We've
made that a lot easier.
I'm very happy to present ADB
debugging over USB.
It's available for your
pixelbook and your HP Chromebook
X2. The public documentation out
in a week or two, please watch
the links. And more devices
coming soon and makes
development that much easier.
So I said there were three
exciting
developer tools. And the first
two are awesome, but I think the
third one is most exciting and I
truly believe it's going to
knock your socks off. And we
didn't want anybody to go home
with cold feet so we brought
replacement socks for when they
fly off your feet. If you're in
the middle of the audience,
don't be jealous, there's plenty
of socks for everyone and on the
way out of the session, you can
pick them up.
Socks, right? It's your new
developer tool.
I'm going to switch over to the
Chromebook for a quick demo. We
have a terminal. Yes, a
terminal. Yeah, terminal!
Super exciting terminal.
You can
see gitclone, I clone the Chrome
lab,
which you should check out the a
the Code Lab tent. And what's
interesting about this
terminal, it's running inside a
full linux environment. You can
clap for the next one, you can
install an application, Linux
application like Android Studio.
Here we go, Android Studio. More
exciting than a terminal, I
guess.
Here I have the Code Lab loading
up, adding drag and drop, hit
run. Oh, so if you're in the
back and you
can't see, that says Google
Pixelbook,
which means when I press okay,
goes to the build, pushing the
application to the device.
On Device. Yeah.
[ Applause ]
So you can click, oh, we got
keyboard
commands and it's pushed it
straight to the device.
We can program in Android
Studio, push, test the app out
and, of course, you
have your debugging tools. So
this is amazing.
[ Applause ]
I'm so glad the engineering team
let me present this super
exciting announcement.
We're super excited about Linux
home Chromebooks. We have a lot
of questions at Office hours,
what's going on behind the
scenes? How does this work?
I'm going to give you a brief
overview.
Here's Chrome OS, in real life,
it's a
bit
snazzier.
This is hour you Android apps
run on Chrome OS.
We have Linux VM, and we install
great
applications like Tux Racer.
Also, Android Studio and to
achieve the last step, which I
think is most exciting, pushing
straight to the app
and debugging on device, we need
to connect ADB to the android
container. That's simple.
ADB connect command, it's not a
secret
IP address, it's the IP address
for the ABDB on the Android
Container. It is in the public
instructions already.
But here's a pro tip since you
came to our session. For some
situations it's handy to set
up a little SSH tunnel in Chrome
OS that will forward those
connections automatically. Not
necessary, it's helpful in some
situations.
Here's the instructions if
you haven't -- oops. Here are
the instructions if you
haven't seen it, I think we're
number one on hacker news
yesterday or something. That's
kind of exciting.
Please install it on your Google
pixelbook, coming to more
devices soon.
Let us know how it works, try it
out.
So where are we at?
We have an emulator, we have ADB
debugging over USB.
We've got Linux on Chromebooks,
running on studio and you have
socks for the
long coding nights. What's
missing? Nothing, right?
Except, I heard a rumor on the
way
in that some of you don't yet
have a Pixelbook. What? So we're
going to help you out a little
bit with that. On the way out
when you grab your
socks, you can pick
up a coupon for 75% off Google
Pixelbook. Oh, they're kicking
me off the stage. Come to the
code labs. We have two good code
labs. You can make keyboard
input, drag and drop, click on
the dinosaurs, talk to us office
hours today, fill out the
survey. Thank you. Can everyone
come on the stage to bow. We're
done, yes?
Shahid, come on up, Stefan,
Palo. Thank you so much.
Learn How UX Researchers
helped test, refine and evolve
the
latest Material Design guidance
and why
it matters to product
development
>> And I'm Mark.
In today's session, we're hoping
to demonstrate how you can build
really, really fully featured
media playback functionality
into the apps using little code.
We're going to guide you through
the process of building two
applications. We're going to
start by focusing on the video
use case.
We're going to build a video
player app and show you how to
insert ads inside that video
content. And then, we're going
to shift our focus to audio.
We're going to show you how to
play audio in a background
service, show you
how to integrate with Android
media
sessions and new functionality
for downloading for offline
playback.
Like last year, we're hoping
to have mixture of introductory
content and coverage of slightly
more tricky use cases.
Hopefully, something for
everyone.
Exo player is an application
media player. You choose which
version you'd like to use and
bundle the play implementation
into your application as a
dependency.
And what that gives you is
consistent playback
functionality across all
different android versions and
devices.
You can reach more than 99% of
active devices. The project is
open source is hosted on GitHub,
and we have an active community
there and you can file issues
with feature requests, bugs and
you can even send requests.
It is also quite widely used.
There are actually over 200,000
applications on the play store
that are using exoplayer. And
the team is excited to see the
great products you're building
using ExoPlayer. We've been
working hard on stability and
performance improvements behind
the scenes and also on brand new
features.
And in doing that ExoPlayer is
developing into a featured
solution for media playback.
So here's some of the highlights
of the features that we've added
over the past year. There's much
too much to go into detail on
here. But I'd encourage you to
check out the release notes and
the redirectory of our GitHub
project where you can find full
details of all of the changes
included in each new release of
the player.
In today's talk, we're going
to cover a few highlights
including support for
downloading media as I've
mentioned and support for player
notifications. Okay. I think
that's enough on the slides.
Let's get on with live coding.
And for each of the two apps,
video app and audio app, a
mostly empty project. We want to
show you as much of the
interesting code as possible.
We're going to provide a link to
a branch on our GitHub project
where you can check out the code
afterwards if you want to look
at things in more detail. Marc,
are you ready for furious
typing?
>> MARC BACHINGER: Yes, I am.
>> ANDREW LEWIS: Switch to
the laptop, please. The starting
point in time is a mostly empty
project, as I mentioned, and
we're going to make a video
player app where we start
playing the stream as soon as it
comes into the foreground and
stop when we go into the
background.
And the first step is going to
be to add a dependency and this
provides a main interface for
the player you can use to
control. As you can see, Marc's
added a
dependency on the library, which
is the new release that we've
done this week.
He's also added a dependency on
the optional UI module. This
provides some customizable high
level UI components you can put
into your applications for
things, like, showing video
player interview, that's player
view, which we're going to use
today.
And also, provides playback
control view and other
components. And these are all
very customizable. You can
change which icons you're using,
customize the layouts and so on.
Marc has added a player
view, which is going to fill the
activity.
And he's given it an identifier
player underscore view, we'll be
able to access it from code. If
we switch over to the main
activity,
we can see create method, we can
get access to that view using
find view by ID.
And once we've got access to
that view, then the next steps
we're going to
take is to actually initialize
the player.
Okay. So, once we've got our
player view in
the field, let's override the on
start method. And we're going to
initialize the player. To
initialize the player, we're
going to use a static method on
the Exo Player factory called
new simple instance.
It does lots of things for
you. For example, handling the
life cycle of the surface holder
for video output.
You pass in a dependency of a
component.
In this case, we're passing in a
default tract, but you could
pass in your own select
implementation if you wanted to
have much more control over
how track selection's working.
The player's output is going to
appear in that particular view.
Okay.
So the next step is to tell
ExoPlayer what we want to play.
And for that, there are two
parts. The first one is to
provide a factory for data
sources.
Data sources tell ExoPlayer how
to load data, using a particular
stack or loading files from a
local device. In this example,
we're using a default data
source, which is suitable for
many use cases.
It provides loading for
httpURLs, the local disk assets
and resources bundled into your
ADK and so on. If you wanted to,
for example, use the
network stack here, you could
use a CRO net. That's the first
part of telling it what to load,
the next part is specifying a
media source. It's going to
depend on the type of media
you're trying to play. We're
going to be playing an MP4.
And use an extractor media
source.
If you wanted to play dash or HL
S, you would use the
corresponding media sources for
those.
Once we've got our media source,
now we need to prepare the
player to start buffering data.
We'll pass that to the prepare
method and call set play when
ready to tell the player as soon
as it transitions from the
buffering state to the ready
state,
then, playback should begin
automatically. All that remains
is to clean up when the activity
goes into the background. So
we'll override on the stop.
Okay. And in that, we're going
to clear the player reference on
the player view.
And then, we're going to
release the player.
Okay. And this is kind of the
minimal code you need just to
play a video stream.
Let's go ahead and deploy
thatAll that remains is to clean
up when the activity goes into
the background. So we'll
override on the stop. Okay. And
in that, we're going to clear
the player reference on the
player view.
And then, we're going to release
the player. Okay. And this is
kind of the minimal code you
need just to play a video
stream. Let's go ahead and
deploy that to the device now.
And if we could switch to the
phone
please when the application is
being installed on the device,
you should see the device starts
to play automatically.
And you can see that if you tap
on
the video, you get some simple
playback controls. Pretty much
what you'd expect from a video
player app.
So you can pause and resume, and
so on. Okay.
Let's now switch back to the
laptop, please.
So let's imagine we've launched
video app and if we can switch
to the laptop, please. We've
launched our video app. And now
we'd like to think about how
we're going to monetize our
content by showing ads.
This is extremely easy to do
with
ExoPlayer, we've added an IMA
extension,
which makes this very easy. Exo
Player make it easy to use. The
IMA extension is a wrapper
around the interactive media ads
SDK which
provides support for loading XML
in VML format, which is a
standard format for information
about ads. We're going to be
using that for loading ads and
insert it within the content in
the player. Marc's going to
create an ads loader, which is
we're going to use an IMA ads
loader, the object provided by
the IMA extension.
This is going to take the
context
and the URI of an XML document.
We're going to create that and
going to release it in on
destroy.
The reason we're using it, the
ads loader contains information
about which ads have been
played. We want to make sure if
it goes into the background and
comes back into the
foreground, we don't show the
same ads multiple times. As I
mentioned before, media sources
are how we tell Exo Player to
play.
And we use the predictably named
media source. We'll pass in the
content source we want to play.
A data source factory, which
is going to be used to load data
for playing the ads.
And finally, we'll pass in a
group on top of the player and
that's going to be used to show
any user interface associated
with ads. Like, for example, the
skip button.
And building an ads media source
out of a content media source
like this is an example of media
source composition.
And this is something you can do
with ExoPlayer, and we'll do
more examples of it later when
we look at play list.
We prepare the player with the
media source and should be good
to go.
So you can see, hopefully,
hopefully
And building an ads media source
out of a content media source
like this is an example of media
source composition. And this is
something you can do with
ExoPlayer, and we'll do more
examples of it later when we
look at play list. We prepare
the player with the media source
and should be good to go.
So you can see, hopefully,
hopefully this will work. We can
switch to the phone.
We were able to add support for
playing ads with maybe ten or so
line of codes. And actually,
this way of integrating
the IMA SDK gives a good user
experience
because ExoPlayer knows about
which ads are coming up in the
future. And that means that it's
going to be
able to buffer the content in
advance. It can buffer the ads
in advance to give you seamless
transition.
So as you saw, we had a
prerollout at the beginning and
now the time bar
has yellow markers
. And taking care of all of the
difficulty and buffering
everything behind the scenes for
us. Okay. So that's playback.
Now over to Marc to talk about
audio.
>> MARC BACHINGER: Let's switch
to another application and look
a little bit into audio
playback. Audio playback is a
little bit more challenging
because we want to enable the
user to put our application into
the background and use another
application and audio should
still keep playing in the
background.
For this, we are going to
use so-called foreground
service. It's called a
foreground service because we
need to attach notification to
the service and this
notification is in the
foreground, it's visible to the
users, the user is always aware
we are doing some work in the
background.
Such a foreground service is a
mandatory requirement. The
system will kill our service and
the application crashes. So
let's have a look at the
starting point of our foreground
service and
let's switch back to the laptop,
please.
We have the audio player
service, which extends from the
service.
We have already overwritten the
create method.
Where we initialize and prepare
the player with a single media.
We will release our resources
and service is not immediately
destroyed
and can explicitly terminate our
service when we are ready.
When we are finished with audio
playback. The service also
already in the manifest. We have
the simple service element which
just points to our audio player
service clause. And finally, we
need to have a way to start our
service.
We do this in-depth main
activity and the create method
of the main activity. Here, we
create an intent pointing to our
audio player service and then,
we
use a static method of the
ExoPlayer library which starts
the service in the foreground
according to the API level.
So now, let's go back into the
audio player service, again, and
change the code a little bit
where we initialize our player.
Because for audio, we don't want
to
only support playing a single
media item. We want to support
play lists so the user can move
to the next or to the
previous item and can just let
the play display one item over
the other.
We are using a connecting
media source to implement play
lists.
The media source joins together
a number of media sources and
plays them gaplessly. We achieve
a nice user experience for audio
playback.
The source allows us to
dynamically change the play list
so we can add and remove
resources while the player is
playing. Or we can move the
currently playing item in our
play list while the player is
playing.
So Andrew already started to
iterate over the samples, you
are going to create an extractor
media source. But then, we add
the extractor media
source to our media source.
In the end, we compare our
player with this media source
and we are done and we
are supporting play lists with
playing gaplessly and without
rebuffering.
So, but now, let's have a
look at
our service, again, and make it
a proper foreground service.
Before it is said, we need to
attach a notification to our
foreground service. And for
this, we are going to use the
player notification service.
The player notification manager
l not only create the
notification, but it will keep
it nicely in sync with the state
of the player. Each time, the
player state change, the manager
will update an application and
post it to our drawer, again.
And we need to pass a couple
-- we need to pass the context
and the
channel ID, which identifies our
channel to which we post our
notification.
The next parameter is a
string identifier which gives us
a localized name for our
channel. This is the name which
shows up in the
settings dialogue where our user
maybe WACHBT to mute our
notification channel. And then,
the next parameter is a
notification ID to identify.
Identify out notification. And
finally, we need to pass a
so-called media description
adapter.
The manager will use our adapter
to
get information about the
currently playing item. Each
time, the notification is
rebuilt. The adapter is called
to get this information. So we
see that for each of those
callbacks, the player instance
is
-- we can use the player to get
the current window index. The
current window index gives us
the index to pick the sample out
of the samples area, which is
kind of the playlist.
The title to get a title, then
we have a similar method, which
is a longer text which is
displayed in the context in
notification.
And finally, we also provide the
map to make our notification a
little bit nicer.
We just use a convenient
method of
our samples to get such a big
net for each of our samples.
Finally, we also need to provide
a pending intent. This pending
intent is fired when the user
taps on the notification. And we
want to get the user back to our
application. And our example to
the main activity.
So we create an intent
pointing to our main activity
and then, we wrap this intent
into a pending intent which we
are using with the static
method, get activities on the
pending intent.
Here, again, a couple of
arguments, then a request code,
which is zero in our case, we
are not going to use it in our
sample.
And finally, the flag to tell
the system to update any pending
intents already in the queue.
So now, we have this player
notification.
And we now also need
notification listener. This
listener makes our service aware
of the life cycle of our
notification. It has two
methods.
So -- the first method of
notification
started is called -- when the
notification is initially
created. Here, we are past those
two arguments to the start
foreground service. And this is
now the moment where our
service is officially foreground
service.
We are now safe, the system is
not going to kill our service
anymore. The next method, then,
is called when
the notification is counselled.
We want to terminate the
service.
And finally, we also need to --
we set the player, set player
method on the notification. So
the notification miniature can
sync the player state to the
notification. So that's about
it.
We also need to clean up in the
destroy method. We know the set,
the player instance, again, so
we don't leak a player reference
when the service is being
destroyed.
And finally, we also need to
-- we set the player, set player
method on the notification. So
the notification miniature can
sync the player state to the
notification. So that's about
it. We also need to clean up in
the destroy method. We know the
set, the player instance, again,
so we don't leak a player
reference when the service is
being destroyed. So now, please
change back to the phone.
And if we've done everything
right, we
should now be able to hear the
play list playing in our
service.
We see the notification. And
let's have a look at the
notification in the drawer. We
see here the information that
comes from our adapter.
He can skip to the next item.
And if we tap on the
notification, it gets us back to
the application.
So fine. As a next step, we have
seen now that this notification
contains information about the
current item and about the
state.
And it lets the user -- what if
we want to expose this to
external application?
Can we go back to the slides,
please?
Google Assistant, for example,
may want to -- yeah. Here we go.
wants to allow the user to use
voice commands to
control media playback.
Let the user remote control --
remote control media application
and browse in a media
application. The Android
framework has a solution for
this.
Because we essentially need to
provide three things to let
external application participate
in media playback.
First, we need to expose the
playback state. The player state
itself, the current media item
or the play list with which we
prepared our player.
Second, we need to be able to
retrieve
playback commands from external
command, external application so
we can execute on our player
instance.
And third, we need to provide
ways to browse in our media
catalog. The android framework
provides a
solution
. We are not going into the
detail of the media browser
service because we don't have
time for this.
Which allows us to expose the
playback state and retrieve
playback commands.
In our code sample, we are going
to media session connector,
which is part
of the media session extension
of the exoPlayer library.
This synchronizes the player
state and retrieves commands
from the media session. So let's
change, again, back to the
laptop, please.
So can see how we can do this in
code.
We are, again, in the on create
method of our player of our
audio player service, and we are
now going to create an instance
of media session compiled. We
assign it to a field.
We just call media session --
which is just the string. Then,
we immediately set our media
session to active by passing
through to the set active
method.
Now, as a first step, we
want to make the player
notification miniature aware of
our session. And we pass the
token to the player
notification miniature so can
enhance the media style
notification and provide
an artwork for our lock screen
of our device.
But now, we are going to create
such
a media session connecter. We
call the constructer and we pass
the
media session to the connecter.
We said we want to synchronize
our play list with the queue.
External application, no, what
items we are having in our play
list.
For this, we are going to use a
timeline queue navigator.
It's after the player has been
prepared. There are as many
windows in our timeline as we
have items in our playlist.
So with this, we can use the
window
index, which is the parameter,
which is passed to our method.
We are going to override to
create, to get the samples,
again, out of our samples area.
And we are then going to create
a media description for such a
sample.
Let's have a look in this --
media
description method to see
there's not much magic behind
it. We see, we are just using
media description builder. And
then, populate this data with
the data from our samples.
And then, we build such a media
description, which are
connecter.
So now, we have already media
session connecter as a next
step, again, we need to pass the
player to the connecter so
he can sync the player with the
media session. We use the set
player method, the first
parameter is the player itself.
The second parameter is a
playback prepare. We are not
going to use it because we don't
want to allow external
application to initiate playback
in our sample.
So that's kind of it.
Again, we need to clean up.
First, we just release the media
session, and the second step,
again, set the player instance
-- this time in the connector to
avoid leaking an instance of the
player. So now, that's kind of
it. If everything is correct, we
should be
able to deploy the application,
So that's kind of it. Again,
we need to clean up. First, we
just release the media session,
and the second step, again, set
the player instance -- this time
in the connector to avoid
leaking an instance of the
player. So now, that's kind of
it. If everything is correct, we
should be able to deploy the
application, again.
Please switch to the phone,
again,
and Andrew should now be able to
use
Google Assistant to skip to the
next item. Let's see if this
works.
>> ANDREW LEWIS: Play next
track. Fine, well done. Thank
you.
And now,
Thank you, Marc. If we can
switch back to the slides,
please.
And
another feature of media apps
I'm sure you're all familiar
with is support for
downloading media for offline
playback. If your users are
going to be in a situation where
they have no connectivity or
intermittent connectivity.
And this has been a much
requested feature for a while
now and we're really pleased
we've been able to launch this
in the 2.8.0 release this week.
ExoPlayer, built on top of our
support for caching.
So I'm going to say a little bit
about how caching fits into the
picture of the player set-up and
we'll look at how
downloading builds on top of
that. This diagram is intended
to show the
data flow when playing one MP3.
We have a as long which is in
the cloud somewhere, a data
source, which is requesting that
over http. And a media source
getting information and
providing it to the player.
Let's see how caching fits
into this.
Well, it's quite simple, we add
a cache data source. That sits
in between the data source we're
using for loading from the
network and the media source
that's providing data to the
player.
And it's going to be
responsible for dealing with a
cache instance. In this case,
we're using a simple
cache provided by ExoPlayer
called library. The way this
works is as follows. When the
media source request some data,
it's going to ask the cache data
source to provide that
information. The cache data
source is going to look in the
cache. We can get the data from
local storage, that goes to the
media source and we never had to
go to the network.
On the other hand, if the data
is not present in the cache,
we've got a cache miss, then the
cache data source needs to go to
the data source that's being
used to load from the network.
And it's going to request the
data from there and it's going
to store it in the cache when it
arrives.
And
You can see also on this
diagram, we've got a cache
evictor. This component is
responsible for making sure that
our cache doesn't grow
indefinitely as we play more and
more different media items.
Okay. Now, let's think about
downloading.
Downloading is a separate
operation, which you might want
to perform in a background.
Might need a service. And this
downloading operation, what's
going on internally is it's
going to
read through the entire stream
and it'll be populating the same
cache instance that you'll be
using for playback. And as you
can probably guess, when you do
this operation, if you've
populated the cache with all of
the data, when it comes to
playback, your player's going to
be able to get everything from
the cache data source. There's
never a need to go to the
network in this case.
One very important thing to
note is that we've got a no up
cache evictor. It does nothing.
It's never going to evict data
from the cache. The reason we
have that is that we don't want
to have a situation whereby
we're downloading the stream and
when we've downloaded up to a
certain amount
of data, we start getting rid of
data at the beginning of the
stream. That would be annoying
for users.
Okay. That's the theory. Let's
see how this works in practice.
If we could switch back to the
laptop, please. We're going to
do this in three steps. The
first step is we're going to add
support for caching to our
player. Then, we're going to
implement an audio download
service, which is going to run
the download operation in the
background.
And then, finally, we're going
to add minimal piece of UI to
our activity in order to let us
trigger the downloads to take
place. Okay.
So we'll go ahead and create a
cache data source factory. And
this is going to sit between our
data source factory for loading
from the network and the media
source, which is actually going
to be extracting the media.
Let's jump into that and see
what's going on there.
It's important that we have a
singleton for the whole process.
We're checking to see if we've
got one already. If we don't
have one, we're going to create
a file which is pointing to a
directory where we're going to
store the downloads.
Then a simple cache, passing in
the directory and also a no-up
cache evictor which is important
because we don't want to be
removing data from the cache.
That's how we make a simple
cache.
We need to introduce a local
variable for that. And then,
we're going to use that cache
data source factory in place of
the data source factory we were
using before for loading from
the network.
We provide a super class for
download service for your
download services that you'll be
putting in your application,
we'll be inheriting
-- the most important one,
important
not to forget is add a
declaration.
So let's start doing that.
We'll create a constructer with
no arguments but then we're
going to call the super
constructer and pass in
information about the download
notifications. Notification ID
must be different from the one
we used for audio playback.
We'll use the notification, pass
in a channel ID for a download
notification channel.
Finally, we also need a string
resource that describes the
notification channel. And that
works the same as the one we did
for audio playback that had the
notification channel, as well.
Now we need to override some
methods.
Let's have a look at those. The
first one is we need to provide
a download manager, and we have
a utility method for this, which
we'll have a look at in a
second.
A single instance for the
download manager for the whole
process.
This is also creating a file,
down loads in progress.
And one substantiating a
download, pass income the same
cache instance as the one we're
using for the cache during
playback. You can see there's a
data source
factory for loading data. We're
downloading progressive media.
We're going to leave this
returning null, but you would
want to provide some
kind of job scheduler.
You can have a look at our
full demo app for an example of
how to do that.
Finally, we're going to provide
a
progress notification and we've
got a handy utility method to
build on here. This is going to
take a context, icon which is
going to be shown in the
notification associated with the
download in progress.
And we'll just use your
playback
icon for
that -- then we provide the
download channel ID, which is
the same one we used earlier.
This is a string not a resource.
One parameter for the head.
We get our download channel ID.
Mixed up with parameters here.
If you remove download channel
name.
Easily done.
Lots of parameters, then the
message is no, content intent is
null, the message
is null and
pass status. What the status is.
That's a lot of parameters.
So that looks pretty good. And
that's implementing our download
service. The final step, I
promise, is just providing a way
to trigger these down loads from
our activity. So as you can see,
we've got an empty list view
here. We're going to replace
that with a list of samples.
We've got three items and a
playlist. When the user taps one
of those, they're going to
trigger the download to start.
And to do that, we'll be
creating a progressive download
action.
If you were downloading a
different kind of content, like
a dash stream, you would not use
progressive action, you would
use the corresponding for the
types of stream you're
downloading.
That's going to take a UI.
If you don't want to associate
any custom data, we'll pass null
for the data and the custom
cache key.
Once we've created our
progressive download action, all
that remains is to call a method
on the download service, there's
a static method to start the
service with that action. And
that takes a context, which is
main
activity -- not the item click,
this and this, okay. It takes
the class of the download
service, which is audio download
service.class.
It takes the download A, which
we've created, progressive
download action.
And finally, we can pass
foreground because the activity
is in the foreground.
It's quite a few bits to
remember, but hopefully, we've
got everything, let's give that
a try and see if it works.
We had plans to show you putting
the device into flight mode.
Unfortunately, we're having to
use cast to play the stream. We
won't actually be able to show
you the -- putting the device in
flight mode. You'll need to use
your imagination.
As you can see, when we tap the
items, you get a play icon,
which is the download
notification.
And that's going to progress as
the download progresses. And
that's populating the cache in
the background.
So that was pretty much it for
downloading.
I'm going
to going to hand it back to
Marc.
>> MARC BACHINGER: There was one
important integration we did not
cover in code is the integration
with Google Cast. Google Cast is
almost expected by all
users, users to be supported by
media
apps.
Calls for application pretty
easier. Let's switch to the
slides, again, please.
The cast extension takes
advantage
of the player interface of the
ExoPlayer library. All of the UI
components and the components
like -- take advantage of this
player
interface and only rely on this
player interface. The most
prominent implementation of
this player interface is a
simple ExoPlayer.
Almost all applications use the
simple ExoPlayer for local
playback.
The Cast extension adds another
implementation, which is the
cost player.
The cost player wraps the cost
SDK, so
it gets pretty easy to swap
local
playback done with a simple
ExoPlayer.
So because all of those
components of the ExoPlayer
library, only rely on the player
interface, you can exchange this
local playback with remote
playback quite easily.
You can also have a look at the
cast application can that we
added to the
GitHub repository and a blog
post on medium which shows you
how to set up the Cast parts for
your application.
>> ANDREW LEWIS: Thank you,
Marc.
And all that remains, really, is
to provide you with a link to
the branch that has the code. Or
at least it'll be similar to the
code we've written today. And
please go and check that out and
try it out. You'll actually be
able to try the download
functionality by putting your
device into flight mode and
making sure it puts it back.
Please check that out. We have
an office hour session today at
3:30. Please come along if
you've got questions and lots of
members of the
team will be there and we'd be
delighted
to find out what you're doing
with ExoPlayer and how we can
help you with that. This is a
link to our project if you
haven't seen that before.
We have a developer guide,
which takes you through the
process of getting
started with ExoPlayer at a
slower pace.
And finally, as Marc alluded to,
we have a blog on medium where
members of the ExoPlayer team
are writing blog posts about new
functionality that we're working
on. Check that out and
subscribe. And with that, thank
you very much.
Yep.
What's new with sign up and
sign in
on the web
>> EIJI KITAMURA: Hello,
everyone. I'm working on the web
at Google.
So today's session is about
what's new
with sign up and sign in on the
web. Are you enjoying Google so
far?
We only have a few hours left
for rest
of Google I/O, but I'm pretty
sure you'll be excited to learn
new things from this session.
Okay.
So I need your help with this
clicker.
So let me start with this
question.
For you, what makes good sign up
and sign in? We consider there
are three principles. First,
good security.
Sign-in is the most important
gate
keeper for a website to protect
user's
information from abusive
behaviors and attackers.
Building a website with a
vulnerable sign-in mechanism
means giving attackers a chance
to abuse the website and in the
worst case, it critically
damages your business.
So building your website with
first class security is quite
important.
But that doesn't mean that
you can sacrifice user
experience.
In many cases, adding better
security
creates more obstacles and
brings more friction for your
users to enter your website.
Thinking about users, user first
web experience, you should make
sure logging
into your website is as seamless
as possible while having good
security.
And finally, good sign-up and
sign-in are often overlooked as
a critical part of user flow.
Developers tend to be more
excited
about new ideas and innovative
features and paying less
attention to make the
sign-up and sign-in secure and
low friction.
It's important that building
them is easy enough and low
cost.
With that in mind, today, we'll
cover three topics.
One sign-up and auto sign-in.
ReCAPTCHA.
Using user name and password is
challenging. I'm not saying it's
technically impossible, but the
user's safety
heavily relies on how they
create their own passwords.
Their passwords could be weak,
forgotten, reused or stolen
. Balazs is going to explain
later in this session. This is
why we've been recommending
identity
federation for years. It's a way
of signing up or signing in
by using an account on the
website. Which is called
identity provider. Identity
federation is usually built
upon standards called, such as,
open ended connect.
Users do not need to create
additional passwords.
You can delicate security
challenges to identity provider.
And you can receive profile
information from that identity
provider.
And as many of you know, Google
is
identity providers, you can
already take
advantage of Google sign-in on
your website.
As Google I/O last year, I
talked about
a JavaScript library that makes
sign-up easier. And last year,
we officially announced
it as sign-up and auto sign-in.
It's a new user experience for
identity federation with Google
that allows users
to sign up with one -- we have a
number of partners already on
board or implementing with this
library.
And they're producing amazing
results.
Let me briefly talk about a few
of them.
So 80% increase in sign-ups
after implementing sign-up.
Also, over 40% of these new
users return to their website
more than five times after
signing up.
One of the world's top search
engines,
it gained 50% more new sign-ups
with TIS
as many users after implement
inging this library.
Cifroclub for chorus, lyrics
and
songs got 40% more after
implementing
the one-tap sign-up. 4,300% more
users. That's an incredible
number.
And user engagement, such as
favoriting artists, commenting,
liking has also increased almost
50% per user.
This is impressive.
So here's how it works.
The user opens the sign-up page,
selects one of the Google
accounts and they're signed up.
It's just that.
It takes less than ten seconds.
It might be too quick to catch
up what's going on.
It's actually that easy. One-tap
sign-up is revolutionary because
on top of the benefits that I
have briefly mentioned earlier
in the session for identity
federation in
general is complete
ly -- and requires only one-tap
for users to sign up. No email
verification is required.
Think about it, you have to
open up
email client, find the right
email and clicking a link in
that email.
Kind of a hassle, right? You can
completely eliminate that step
from the user. It's a big deal.
And third, it works across all
modem browsers.
Using this API is quite simple.
Start with loading this
JavaScript library.
Once it's loaded,
Google I/O and it'll show an
account user.
You need to create a client ID
in
advance. This is a powerful API,
we are reviewing sites that are
making use of this library.
The process will resolve and you
will
receive a result that contains
-- to verify the user's identity
on your server. If you already
have a Google sign-in, back in,
you can reuse it.
Once the ID token's verified,
extract the user's profile you
mentioned and establish a new
session. And the user is signed
up.
When the user session expires or
the user lands on your website
from a
different device, you can let
them -- you can let the user
sign back in automatically.
To perform the sign-in, call
Google -- to obtain the ID
token.
Resume that session.
By the way, you might have heard
about the API. It's an open web
API to handle credentials using
JavaScript.
The one-tap library actually
uses this credential management
API behind the scenes.
And there's a password for the
website.
If you want to retrieve using
password, add Google password.
It will give you a user name and
password instead of an ID token.
So you can use that information
to authenticate the user.
When a user clicks the button,
the user probably wants to keep
signed out.
In that case,
sign-in will start returning ID
token
until the user explicit
ly signs back in. Let me recap.
One-tap sign-up is secure
because it's Google's identity
federation.
Provides a great user experience
to
sign up with one-tap and auto
sign-in. It's easy to implement
with simple APIs.
To learn more, visit developers
at Google.com and find more
documentation.
Okay, so far, I've been
talking about identity
federation.
But I guess that many of you
might be
interested in some solutions
about when
you are using passwords, user
name and password. Earlier on in
this session, I talked about
challenges with passwords. What
can you do if an attacker
already
knows your user's password and
tries to hijack account?
And in many cases, account
hijacking is done by bots. This
means, if you could filter out
bots, the number of account
hijacks should decrease.
And that's what we -- six years
ago,
it asked users
to redistorted text like this.
We then developed reCAPTCHA v2.
It is smart enough to determine
if an interaction is abusive
just with that simple gesture.
And if recapture is still
uncertain,
it asks an additional challenge,
like
select only with a street sign.
This is an example question.
Many bots cannot answer easily.
And we are protecting over 2
million websites every week from
spam and abuse.
But bots evolve, also.
The attacks against
reCAPT
CHA have evolved to martyr and
Aibots. Trying to break these
challenges and
attack websites. We want to stop
bots whether or not they can
find the street signs in a set
of images.
Today, we are announcing public
beta
of reCAPTCHA v3, this comes with
three new things at a high
level.
First, it requires no
interactive challenges.
Two, it scores traffic and
third, it breaks down your
traffic by action. Let me walk
you through each one.
In v3, whether an interaction
with
the website is abuseive.
This means, you can keep your
website
safe without interacting any
users.
. And instead of simple yes or
no answer, it will give you a
score, which ranges from zero to
1.0. The score is color coated
by the
capture risk analysis engine.
And interactions with the
website.
Based on the score, you can
define your
own threshold to determine
whether you
should do farther verification
on the tests.
Let's say, you get a request
with low score of 0.2. In that
case, for example, you can
request an additional
authentication
factor such as email
verification.
Or, send an email to an admin to
ask for moderation. Or search
requests from bots as a
protection from scraping.
To use recapture, first, load
the JavaScript library. When the
user submits a form, recapture
tokens and finally, submit the
form along with the obtain
token.
One nice thing about v3 is that
it enables you to put it into
almost all parts of your
website. Not only the sign-up
page, but also, many other
places.
For example, from home page to
reading path, log-ins, adding
comments and searches.
Wherever your website has
potentially risky actions, you
can protect with recapture.
You can define a tag for each
action.
Actions will also become a
signal into
the adaptive risk analysis
engine.
As a result, you can treat
scores differently depending on
the actions. Also, you can see
the traffic breakdown
and score distribution in
action.
So that's recapture v3. Let me
recap.
ReCAPTCHA, doesn't require to
eliminate challenges. So there's
zero friction.
It gives you is the flexibility
as to how you want to treat
suspicious traffic.
To learn more, please visit g.
co/
repcaptcha/v3io. I've been
talking about figures from
Google. But I'd like to make a
transition to talk about open
web API.
The credential management
API. I briefly talked about it
earlier in the session.
As each focuses on identity
federation with Google, if you
choose to use other identity
options such as user name and
password, you should use
credential management API.
We have already covered this
topic at Google I/O last year.
So let me quickly recap.
It's an open web API that allows
you to handle credentials using
JavaScript.
With this API, you can enable
things like auto sign in or sign
in with browsers, account
chooser.
It can handle two different
types of credentials
. Password credential and
federative credential. And now,
we have a new kind of credential
being added to the API, which is
called public key credential.
With that, let me invite Balazs
to talk about identification.
>> BALAZS ENGEDY: Hello,
everyone.
I'm a software engineer on the
Chrome Web Identity team.
And already mentioned that
passwords create a number of
issues. I would like to talk a
little bit more about two of
them in particular.
The first one is password reuse.
When your users are using the
same password on multiple
different websites
and the second one is phishing.
Tricking users into entering
their credentials into fake
websites. Historically, these
issues have been really hard for
developers to address because
they both have to do with your
users being only human.
Suppose one of your users, call
her Jane Doe has accounts on 50
different websites.
What do you think? On how
many other websites is Jane
using the same password she's
using on your site?
To answer that question, we've
calculated some statistics
client side among Chrome manager
users. And if Jane is anything
like them, she will be reusing
that password on ten different
websites. That's 20% of all her
accounts.
What does that mean? It means
that if Jane's password is
compromised on any one of those
ten websites, it's compromised
on all of them, including yours.
So how often does this happen?
According to another study,
during a
period of just one year, data
breaches exposed a total of 1.
9 billion user names and
passwords. This means that even
if you have implemented all of
the password management best
practices. For instance, you
serve your log-in
page and perceivably entire
website, you never store or log
plain text passwords.
You always hash passwords and
maybe even more. You're still
not done.
Suppose, you're using
two-factor authentication. To
log in, Jane has to enter her
password plus an OTP.
A one-time pass word, for
instance, a six-digityou never
store or log plain text
passwords. You always hash
passwords and maybe even more.
You're still not done.
Suppose, you're using two-factor
authentication. To log in, Jane
has to enter her password plus
an OTP. A one-time pass word,
for instance, a six-digit number
she receives to her phone.
Surely Jane is safe now, right?
Well, unfortunately, OTPs are
phished as easily as passwords.
As soon as Jane enters her
password into the phishing page,
the attacker connects to the
real website and initiates a
log-in flow using the freshly
stolen passwords.
The real website asks the
attacker
for the OTP, the attacker then
asks Jane.
In the meantime, the six-digit
number is sent to her phone.
Jane is under the impression
she's
logging into the real website so
she expects she gets asked for
the one-time password. As soon
as it arrives, she enters it
into the phishing page.
The attacker forwards the OTP
for the real website and gained
access to her account.
Similar attacks are possible
if Jane
is using time-based OTPs,
generated by
an app on her phone or a
hardware token.
Or if the sign-in, Jane has to
confirm
that log-in attempt on her
mobile device. The problem is in
all of these cases,
we rely on Jane, a human, to
recognize when she's not on the
real website but on a phishing
page.
Remember, the study from before.
It also estimates that around
12.4 million users fell victim
to phishing during the same
one-year period. This is why
last year at I/O, we recommended
using security keys, instead.
Many of you are familiar
with the universal factor
security keys that look like
this. Some of you may even be
using them for two-factor
verification already.
The main advantage of security
keys
over OTPs is that they cannot be
fooled by phishing. Security
keys talk directly to the
browser. They can easily verify
that the URL of
the pastime that Jane is
visiting is the a slightly
different URL corresponding to a
phishing site.
This E are removes the human
error factor.
How come we aren't all using
them on every website already
today?
Unfortunately, a key piece
of the puzzle have been missing.
Previously, there haven't been a
good way to access security keys
on the web. Some of you are
already familiar with
the API which was a great first
step but also had a number of
limitations.
For instance, it wasn't
available across all browsers.
And this is
why -- the web platform API that
provides a strong authentication
on the web.
The new API is coming to
major browsers and made
available on both
mobile and desk
top.
The initial feature set with the
latest Chrome beta. Let's see
what makes this API so great.
First, it's backwards compatible
with existing security keys, the
same key
that you registered through the
U2F API can be used through the
web authentication API.
That means, you can migrate your
site
to U2F without any visible
changes.
But it's much more than just a
new API.
In a variety of form factors
that are
much more exciting than USB
hardware tokens. So if they are
not your cup of tea, don't fall
asleep just yet.
Also brings many new features
that enable exciting new use
cases. The single most important
feature is
probably that authenticators can
now perform user verification.
This means that the
authenticator can
locally verify the user if Jane
drops her authenticator on the
street, you cannot pick it up
and use it. It only responds to
Jane.
User verification can take
many forms.
It can be done using biometrics.
The built-in finger print
readerimportant feature is
probably that authenticators can
now perform user verification.
This means that the
authenticator can locally verify
the user if Jane drops her
authenticator on the street, you
cannot pick it up and use it. It
only responds to Jane.
User verification can take many
forms. It can be done using
biometrics. The built-in finger
print reader in your notebook or
phone.
They do not need to be combined
with passwords to implement two
factor authentication. There is
already something that you have
and something that you are. So
you get great security. And you
also get a great user
experience. You no longer have
to type your password.
It's especially frustrating on
mobile devices.
Let me show you what I'm talking
about. Can I switch the demo
device, please?
Suppose that I'm browsing the
web and I find something I want
to buy.
I have a pixel 2 phone with a
finger sensor. Suppose I have
this chemical cleaning kit
that's a good deal for ten
cents, I add it to my cart.
Then, I go to check out
-- and then, I choose to
complete my
checkout with paypal.
I get redirected to paypal.
And because paypal supports the
web
authentication API, I can easily
verify
my identity using just my
fingerprint. Sorry.
Select the credit card.
And there. My order is
confirmed.
So I didn't have to type -- it
was so much better user
experience. Back to the slides,
please.
How does it all work?
First, let's take a look at how
authenticators work in the first
place.
All the authenticators
use -- there's a one-time set-up
in which the user registers an
authenticator in an account.
During registration, the
authenticator generates a new
public/private keeper.
It can be extracted from the
authenticator.
Then every
time -- they possess the private
key. This is done through a
challenged response base.
Sends a challenge, which in turn
uses
the private key to provide a
cryptographic signature. It
verifies it against the public
key and the challenge.
Releasing the signature is --
such as a fingerprint scan. The
finger never leaves the device,
it's only used to locally unlock
the authenticator.
You did not see this in the
demo. I already did this last
week. There are three important
participants in this flow.
Suppose that
-- such as a fingerprint scan.
The finger never leaves the
device, it's only used to
locally unlock the
authenticator. You did not see
this in the demo. I already did
this last week. There are three
important participants in this
flow. Suppose that it is once,
again, Jane who is now setting
up the fingerprint reader in her
phone as an authenticator.
To kick off the registration
flow, the server first generates
a challenge. A large, random
number that will be only used
for the registration process and
thrown away later.
The server stores a challenge in
association with the user
account and transmits it along
with user information to the web
app running in the browser.
The web app then calls the web
app.
It extends the credential
management API so it's available
under navigator.credentials.
To create a new public key
credential, you specify the
challenge, you received from the
server, user information that
will be displayed on the
authenticator
if it has a display and the
crypto items you wish to use.
In addition to the
parameters specified, the
browser also extracts the
authoritative domain name. Then,
all of this information is sent
to the authenticator which asks
for user consent.
This is required so that
malicious websites cannot use
the API to track the user. This
protects the user's privacy.
Once user consent is given, the
authenticator generates a new
public/private keeper.
It stores the private key
internally along with the user
information and importantly, the
domain name, the credential
belongs to.
And then, the API core contains
the unique identifier, the
public key and
the signature, the challenge,
the domain name, the public key,
the credential ID and some other
parameters.
And the web app, there you need
to validate the signature and
there's a last step. If the
signature checks out, the server
has to store the credential ID
and the public key in
association with the user
account.
And don't forget to invalidate
the challenge.
This concludes the registration
flow. And, remember, you only
have to do this once.
Now, let's take a closer look at
how Jane can use the
authenticator to log in without
a pass word the next time.
The authenticator already has a
private key and the server has a
corresponding public key in
association with Jane's account.
Remember that authentication is
performed using a challenge
response
based protocol where Jane
calculates the cryptographic
signature to prove possession of
the private key.
So once, again, the flow starts
with the server generating a
challenge, a large random number
which is used to prevent replay
attacks. Then, the server
transmits the credential ID and
the challenge to the
web application which in turn
calls the web awe
THENTuthentication API.
To create a cryptographic
signature, you need to call with
the public key option. You
specify the challenge that you
received from the server, the
credential
for which you want to get
cryptographic signature.
And here, you see that we also
ask the authenticator to locally
verify the user.
In addition to these parameters
we
specified, once again, the
browser inspects and sends all
of the information to the
authenticator.
The authenticator looks up
information stored for the
credential ID. Next, and this is
important, the authenticator
checks that the domain name of
the calling website matches the
one that was provided at the
time the credential was created.
This is what makes these
authenticators resistant to
phishing. If Jane is on the
phishing page with a slightly
different URL, the
authenticator will
not notice the discrepancy. The
authenticator provides local
verification using the
fingerprint reader.
If the fingerprint checks out,
the authenticator uses the
private key to
generate a cryptographic
signature over the domain name
and the challenge.
It's sent to the server.
There, once again, it is
verified it corresponds to the
challenge.
And if it does, the server
considers the authentication
successful. And the last step,
again, don't forget to
invalidate the challenge.
This concludes the
registration --
sorry the authentication flow.
But if you have the large user
base, you know you cannot
replace your ID management
overnight.
What's also great about, it
enables you to adopt it one at a
time. You can use more and more
of the API to get more and more
of the security and the
usability benefits.
First, you can use it as a
drop-in
replacement for the U2F API.
Then, with minimal changes, you
can implement authentications,
such as making a purchase.
This can be done using
theenables you to adopt it one
at a time. You can use more and
more of the API to get more and
more of the security and the
usability benefits.
First, you can use it as a
drop-in replacement for the U2F
API. Then, with minimal changes,
you can implement
authentications, such as making
a purchase. This can be done
using the fingerprint reader
built into your phone or mobile
device.
And finally, once your users
warm up to the idea of signing
in using a fingerprint or a
hardware token, you might
consider making it the primary
log-in mechanism.
To summarize, we talked about
the web authentication API,
which provides strong
authentication on the web using
public key cryptography.
Enabling a password log-in
experience making it easy for
users to sign into your site
securely.
It all comes in the form of the
simply used, which is available
across all platforms and
browsers.
With that, let me hand it back
to Eiji to wrap it up.
>> EIJI KITAMURA: Okay. Thank
you.
We've been working through new
exciting features in the web.
One-tap sign-up and autosign-in
for low friction signing up and
signing in.
ReCAPTCHA and web authentication
with
API.
We have published --
what makes good signup and good
sign-in.
Great security, great user
experience, and great developer
experience.
If you have any questions,
please visit
us, the website
Sandbox, and we'd love your
feedback on our session today at
Google.
com/ioschedule. We hope you
enjoyed our talk. Thank you very
much.
Material Metrics: Learn about
the
research-backed validation for
adopting
Material Design
>> Good afternoon, everybody,
I'm
Elizabeth Churchill, and I head
up research for material design.
I'm sure you've been hearing
about the innovations that
material has brought out
recently here at I/O. And we've
done a lot of research in the
background.
To back up much of that
innovation.
And what we're going to do today
is just tell you a little bit
about some of
that research.
We're going to encourage you
to come talk to us later. We're
interested in knowing how you're
integrating research into your
product and design system
development.
But before I get going, I want
to know how many people out
there consider themselves to be
developers. Yay. Welcome, thank
you for coming.
Finally, researchers. Yay,
research.
Welcome, welcome, welcome. One
of the things we want to
emphasize
in this talk and that material
is
extremely committed to is that
we
believe the tight collaboration
between
engineering and development
design and research really is
the key to creating great user
experiences. And by user
experiences, I mean the users
are the things that you build
but also, you as users. Because
in material, as you will see and
you've been hearing, we build
products for you so that you can
build great products for your
users.
So I just wanted to go over a
few things about material which
you may know. Just to remind
you.
So the material design system is
open source.
It's adaptable and helps you
bring high-quality experiences
to your users. And our aim is to
help you make things
that are beautiful but that are
usable and useful.
And also, importantly
accessible.
We're very committed to helping
you do that.
So material consists of
components
and components are things, like,
buttons, things like text
fields, and things like tables.
You're familiar with that.
At this I/O, we have brought
material theming into the
picture. And we've heard you and
we have responded because we
want to make all of
these components customizable so
that
you can adapt them for your
experience so that you can have
your brand and your
look and feel for your users all
the way
through systematically from
design to code.
So that's very much a key part
of our innovation
. Material also consists of
patterns. Patterns like account
switching,
accessing settings or handling
empty states.
They roll up into guidance
that you can see on our site,
our spec. If you have not
checked out material.io, please
do so, please go and have a
look. Check out what we've got
there, and send us feedback.
Because a great part of this
talk is to
remind you
that we can shape great
experiences with the help of
folks like you. So we need your
feedback.
Material, also, as I mentioned
has a Suite of products and
tools that are designed for you.
One of them is here.
This is Gallery, and Sara's
going to be
talking about Gallery in a bit
of detail a bit later.
It was launched here at I/O, and
we want your feedback. Gallery
will allow you to take the
components, the themes and that
guidance and turn it into
reality. We're really building
these tools to build this
relationship and this
collaboration. The deep
collaboration between design and
development.
Just as a pause, this is the
outline of the kinds of research
we do in this team in the
material experience research
team.
The most granular research
is on components, and Michael is
going to be taking you through
some of that.
Here we look to make sure the
components really are beautiful
and
usable and useful and
accessible.
The next level of research is
the product research on things
like Gallery.
And here, again, we use
interviews and
observations and we work with
folks like you to make these
tools great. Sara's going to be
taking you through some of that.
Finally, we look at work flow.
Where do all of these tools fit
into your lives as a designer
and developer. How do you pull
these together to accomplish the
things you need?
What is the bigger ecosystem of
the
idea to design, to develop, to
iterate work flow? And again, we
do interviews, we do behavioral
studies. We observe folks in
workplaces, like where you work.
We do surveys to try and
understand
where our tools fit in for you
now, how we can improve them.
And to start to think about
where we need to go in the
future as the whole
field explores and innovates.
And Sara is going to help you
with that.
So with that said, from our
studies
with a few users to thousands of
users, from our close studies as
we talk to you to our surveys,
we're going to give you
a bit of a flavor of that today.
And I'd like to hand off to
Michael who is going to talk
about components research.
>> MICHAEL GILBERT: Well, thank
you for the introduction,
Elizabeth. And once again,
welcome everyone.
My name is Michael and I lead up
research on material system.
So as Elizabeth mentioned, we do
research on everything that
covers the minor details of
users' experience all the way up
to the big picture. We look at
everything from how things
look on the web or on your
mobile device to how those
things come together to
form an application or a brand
or an experience.
For today, I'm going to be
focusing on two types of
research that we've done, both
examining the components of a
design system. First, I'll go
into some detail on the top-down
experimental work that we've
done, which looks into how the
details of design can really
impact how your users interact
with your products.
And second, I'll go through some
of the
bottom up,. Focusing on the same
components, but also, aiming to
understand how experiences come
together in our
products and what those
experiences mean to your users.
And by the end, I'm hoping
to give everyone a better
understanding about how we do
some of the research here at
Google so you can take that back
and do it within your own teams.
But first, a little
background on what I mean when I
say components. Elizabeth
already introduced some of
the components, the patterns and
the guidelines available in
material design.
Here, we have three examples of
abstractions of those
components. And just to
introduce them, on the
left, we have the material fab
or the floating action button.
This was introduced in the first
iteration of material design.
And since, has become more of
the more recognizable
characteristics.
In the center, we have the
material text field.
And this provides a core means
for users to input content into
applications. And on the right,
material buttons, which provide
a core means of interacting with
content in applications.
And you probably are all
familiar with these already.
But what I want to call out here
is not that these components are
necessarily
unique or that they're earth
shatteringly critical to any one
single interaction. But that
these components are a
fundamental part of a larger
experience.
And because of that, we want to
make sure that we understand
these components
at a fundamental level. But for
now, we're going to focus just
on this first one. The material
text field.
So this is the text field that
we started with.
This was our baseline.
This text field performed well
and it aligned with the original
material vision.
But there was an opportunity to
make sure that it worked even
better. That it worked across
all devices.
That it worked in both consumer
and enterprise applications.
When you look at something
like this, think of all of the
different parts that have to
come together to make a text
field. There's the underline
that indicates where the field
starts and where it stops.
There's the label that hints at
what
might be typed in there
. The shape of the entire
component how each of those
individual parameters come
together and then how they're
used on a page.
So it's clear that even for a
text
field, there's a lot going on
design wise.
I just want to show a few of the
details that we're considering
here. So what we're looking at
here is an exploration of label
placement as well
as some of the possible values
in consideration for label
placement.
But we also looked at
things, like, background fill,
we looked at different
elements of style, different
types of contrast. And of
course, whether there should be
squared or rounded borders.
In the end, there were over 140
different variations that we
looked at
in a couple of different
contexts.
First, we looked at simple forms
which had stub content that was
procedurally drawn so that we
could test a whole bunch of
them. Second, we looked at real
quote, unquote forms which were
forms that we actually took from
the wild.
And inserted our experimental
text fields.
Third, we looked at complex
forms. And these are forms we
hope you would never encounter,
you know, in nature. They're
unreasonably complex.
But we've created them to see
each text
field would perform in extreme
circumstances.
Would it stand out too much or
get lost entirely?
And we'll show examples of that
one
in a minute. First, what does
that look like? This is
ultimately a tool that we
created that would create each
of those forms with each of
those text fields.
Randomly drawing the layout, the
theme and each of the
characteristics that we
had identified
. We deployed these forms in a
set of large scale surveys so we
could test the performance of
every individual text field as
well as get an idea of what
users actually preferred.
And on the right, you can see
the admin interface for the
tools we build. It's simple, but
allows us to zero in on the
types of designs that we want to
research.
And more importantly, it
provides us with an artifact
that we can share with the
designers and developers who are
creating and building these text
fields.
Maybe you're curious about the
complex forms. This is what I
mean when I say complex forms.
We don't condone their use
in the wild. But this is the
lengths designers will go to
make sure that every opportunity
is explore
d.
What we were able
to do what products SHOUL look
like. We were doing research as
a way of
working with designers to show
them what parts seem to work and
what parts might require
caution.
should look like. We were doing
research as a way of working
with designers to show them what
parts seem to work and what
parts might require caution. To
allow us to more effectively
bring
our users into the conversation.
And this is one example of
what that conversation looks
like.
This is another -- this is what
the data actually is from those
text field experiments. And
without going into too many of
the details, I want to show you
how we were looking at all of
the possible text fields, every
possible combination without
dropping any of those
possibilities because the data
says this or that.
Each step
that -- the landscape and to
provide our designers and
engineers with the
tools that they can use to
create great products.
And here I'm refer to research
and the artifacts from research
as one of those tools.
Here is the before and after
example of what just one text
field might look like given this
approach.
What we aim to do is support
design that is more usable, more
useful, more
beautiful and importantly more
customizable. Especially with
today's enhanced material design
system and the
introduction of material
theming.
We want to emphasize that the
components are customizable and
that within that
customizability, we've done the
leg work to make sure that those
components will still work the
way they should. And
importantly, that they'll still
look the way that you want them
to.
So that's a quick look at
some of what we've done with the
material text field.
But let's take a look at the FAB
and the button next. At the
beginning I mentioned that we'd
be looking at both the top down
experimental research that we've
done.
It usually involves sitting
down with your users across the
table. Sometimes, in something
like usability studies.
Sometimes, in things like
interviews.
Secretly, it looks a lot like
normal conversation.
What we try to do is make
sure we're asking the right
questions.
How long does it take 10,000
users to click on this.
About products and interactions.
Because material design is about
the performance and the
usability of components.
But it is also a look in that
field. So next, I'm going to
show three examples to give you
a sense about how
users feel about these
components and
what that means
for our design. This first
example is for a study
participant that's interacting
with the new material button.
She says, when the boxes are
really bolded like that, it
makes you feel like you're
actually pressing a button.
Sometimes, something like this
in the
middle of interviews will make
you take step back and ask
yourself, what is a button,
really?
These aren't just strictly
questions for fun either.
There's an entire landscape of
what buttons might look like.
Of what they might be
. To better understand and we
get to do that by talking with
our users.
The second example from a study
participant who is interacting
with the Google themed material
FAB.
The last
time, it didn't look as googly
as this. When we actually talked
to our users, we learn about
more than just the components.
We learn about more than just
the interactions or the
products.
And in this example, we can
clearly see how design can
impact brand. But we get a
better sense from the user's own
perspective about what seems to
jump out at them.
And in the end, we can speak
more effectively about the
meaningful characteristics of
brand with the designers and the
developers who are building
these.
And this last example is a quote
from a study participant who
could use assistive devices to
see but he was actually legally
blind.
And I think this is one of
the main strengths
--
these components in our products
are encountered by all of our
users.
It's a different way of looking
at the exact same landscape.
To wrap things up, I've shown
you a brief look at how we've
approached a
couple different types of
research. First, looking at the
material text
field from the top down
experimentally. And second,
looking at the fab and the
button from the bottom up.
I'm hoping you can see some of
the
similarities of these two
approaches.
On the one hand, we're aiming to
better understand a whole range
of possible
expression with the brilliant
designers
and engineers who were building
material design. On the other
hand, we're aiming to
better support our users to make
sure
that each component is usable as
useful,
as beautiful no matter how it's
used or by who.
And last, again, I'm hoping you
might be able to take some of
the ideas
we've
talked about research within in
your own teams. With that, I'd
like to thank you for your time
and welcome Sara to the stage
who is going to be talking about
designer and developer research.
[ Applause ]
>> SARA CAMBRIDGE: Thank you,
Michael. I'm Sara, and I lead
research for material product.
And what we do is create
products and tools, resources
for designers and developers
just like you.
So Michael shared with you how
we do
research with our N users so we
can really understand how to
make our components most
effective.
But you are are N YURDSs, too
users, too. How you're using
them to make the products
better.
What I'm going to talk about is
the other two types of research
Elizabeth mentioned, the work
flow research and product
research. And I'll give you
examples of how products that
have launched here at I/O have
been made better through our
research.
So let's start with work
flow research.
This gives us a really big,
broad picture for how people
creating digital tools, people
like you, how you're doing
your work day in and day out.
I'll interview designers and
developers to work together.
I'll go to your office, I'll
talk to you about how you're
working.
I want to know all of the
tools
you're using, who you're
collaborating with and
especially anything that's a
problem in your work flow. And
our goal with this kind of
research is to get a big picture
of the bigger
problems that affect a lot of
people so we can prioritize
building tools that solve those
problems for you.
So this example is from work
flow research we did with
designers and developers that
work together. Like I said, we
went to their offices.
And one of the things we had
them do is take us through a
recent project from beginning to
end, we had them walk us through
every part of the project, who
they worked with, what the tools
they were using. And especially,
anything that was a struggle.
So here's a couple of
examples of how people think
about their work. So you can
see, people look at their work
in really different ways.
Whenever I do this kind of
research, I
want my developer, designer and
product manager colleagues
working on those products to
come with me. Because everyone
hears different things and
different things pop out at them
during the interviews.
So we always do a debrief where
we compare notes on what we
heard and what was interesting
or surprising. And because this
research was really
focused on understanding the UX
design process itself, we were
going to be doing a time line of
a typical UX design project.
And so, I had my colleagues
categorizing the different
phases that
they heard the people we talked
to went through. Let me show you
what this turned into. This is a
UX design work flow. It's also
known as a journey map or
experience map.
But what we ended up with was
six phases for the design
process.
Discovery, initial design, it
rating on
the design, validating,
beginning building and then, the
final implementation.
And I'll explain the
structure first and then, I'll
come around and fill in some
details. Below that in the green
to red are a
single positive and a negative
key moment in each phase. And
those were from stories we
literally heard from the
participants we talked to that
were either really
meaningful or were a pattern we
heard several people talk about.
And then, the bottom we had
the tasks, pain points and
tools. This gave us a range of
rich experiences that we heard
different people using. I took
that out to simplify it to show
you. But the whole thing is a
poster that hangs in our office.
So for instance, thinking about
the key
moments often we heard people
get really excited when they're
starting a new project. There's
a lot of promise and potential.
But they quickly get overwhelmed
by scope. That becomes a
negative moment.
And there's a lot of
interplay between designers and
developers here. The first one
is when the initial design phase
when a designer is really
excited about an idea they have
and they have to go to their
developer the developer says to
them, this, we cannot build
this. Technical constraints make
this impossible. Anybody here
ever have one of those
conversations? Okay. All right.
That's good we're resonating
with your experience, as well.
But, of course, there's
positive interactions between
designers and developers
throughout this process. We
definitely have heard that
designers
do not enjoy if making design
specs for handing a project off
to a developer. But when that
moment comes where they get to
hand off formally to a
developer, that's usually a
milestone. A positive milestone
in a project. That's positive.
And it can go south, again,
because what happens often is
that developers come back later
with unexpected problems due to
legacy code and the designers
have to step back in often after
they've already moved on to
another project.
Is this resonating? Anybody have
this happen? All right. The
whole point of doing this really
deep dive into understanding the
practices, again, is to surface
those
problems that affect a lot of
people so we can prioritize
building them.
And I just want to take a
minute and
define -- I mentioned design
specs and I'll talk about it
more in a minute. But what I
mean are the margins,
guidelines, colors, fonts and
often even
behaviors that designers give to
developers when they're getting
ready to implement a design.
So another thing that came
out of
that research is pain points of
designers and developers and
I'll go through these with you.
So the key pain points we
heard from designers are having
to aggravate feedback from a lot
of different stakeholders.
Often, the feedback is living in
different tools. Having to
prototype motion but not having
time to do it.
Having to keep track of
different project resources
they're going to need at
different phases of the design
process that often are living in
different places.
Now, remember this because
I'll show
you a solution that we came up
with in Gallery.
Creating design specs and having
to
share designs a assets and
keeping them consistent.
Top pain points for developers
was having to solve for edge
cases and responsiveness from a
singular happy path that they're
getting from their designer.
Getting incomplete design specs
or getting one for the wrong or
not getting them at all. I've
heard that one a lot, as well.
When you have to create a new
component trying to figure out
am I going to customize
something that's existing or
build something new from
scratch?
Giving design changes late after
you've started working, leading
to rework and finally, having a
lack of
context of what the intent was
with the design. Not knowing
what really matters.
So you'll notice with this kind
of list
that
both designers and developers
found design specs as a pain
point. It was this kind of
research that let us realize
what a problem this is for both
roles and let us prioritize
building a tool that solves this
problem.
And that project as mentioned,
is Gallery. And I'm going to
tell you more about Gallery in a
minute. But before I do, I'm
going to tell you a little bit
about the other type of
research I mentioned, product
research. A big bucket for
anytime we show you that we want
to get your feed back on.
It may be a really early stage
idea that we want to validate
and make sure the concept is
sound or maybe it's a refinement
of a product we've already
invested a lot of time in and we
just want to make sure it's
really functioning well for how
you want to use it.
A lot of people call this
usability. But for us, this type
of research is doing so much
more than just telling us if a
product is usable.
So also, let me walk you through
a little bit about how I conduct
research when I'm doing product
research with designers and
developers.
This is one of our research labs
on the left. Usually, I'll bring
somebody into our lab, I'm
meeting with them one-on-one.
It's streaming to a room that my
designer or developer and
product manager colleagues are
sitting in. Like the one on the
left.
And I'll walk you through some
kind of prototype or beta tool.
And getting your feedback as we
go along. What do you like?
What's confusing?
And especially, at the end, I
want to
know, how does this fit into
your existing work flow? Is this
going to create problems?
And go back in, talk to my
colleagues and we figure out
what was really interesting
here? What can we take from this
that we can use to make our
products better? So now, I've
told you a little bit about how
this process works. Let me walk
you through an example of
something we learned when we
were doing research with Gallery
and how that made it better for
the final product.
So has anybody seen a demo of
Gallery in our -- okay, a couple
of folks, let me walk you
through.
This is a project page in
Gallery.
Let me get an overview, Gallery
is
an online collaborative tool.
Colleagues get feedback and it
has a
design specs feature where they
can get the metadata from the
sketch goes into an online way
for developers to get that, the
code and the values.
And then, the developers
also have
an access to material components
in that gallery feature if
they're using the material
components when they're
designing. And it's being demoed
over there if you want to check
it out.
We're in a project call
ed -- as I mentioned, we were
solving one of the problems we
uncovered in the research with
that one.
And then, below that, basically
folders and people can organize
them however they want. And in
this case, they're organized by
the device that it's been
designed for. Let's say, you
clicked into the tablet view
from here, you would see all of
the screens that are in that
tablet. And if you clicked into
the first screen, then you're
going to see that screen in more
detail.
Now, at the yellow box at the
top, you can see all of the
different things you can do from
here.
You can comment, inspect, share
it. But someone has rolled over
the type at
the top, and it's got the type
face, weight, the color, all of
that is there for the developer
to access. That's how it looks
now.
And let me show you something we
were getting feedback on a
couple of months ago when we did
research on it.
This looks a little bit
different. You can see, it's
basically the same thing.
So in the study, what we did is
we were talking to designers. We
had them use our new material
theme editor, which I hope
you've heard about the material
plug-in we have. And that gives
them access to all of these
pre-built material components
where they can customize for
their own brand so the one in
the green bar, the
green bottom app bar had
customized that in sketch and
changed the color and the icons
in there.
And then, they had uploaded that
to Gallery where they were
looking at what
they would be sharing with their
developers. We were wanting to,
you know, what do you think of
this? P ask what we heard from
them is you can see when you
roll over that bottom app bar,
what you're getting is the link
to the code and the specs for
that. But you're not getting any
more granular information beyond
the size of that entire bar. And
what we heard designers saying
is I want to see what that shade
of green I changed it to was.
I want to make sure it's the
right brand color and I want to
see what the icon was. I want to
make sure it's the right icon.
What we heard is they wanted a
lot more granular data for the
material
components than we were showing
them in Gallery. And we had it.
We didn't put it in there. So
this was really important thing
for us to know. So this is the
final version that's been
released. So as you can see,
you've got that bottom app bar,
but when you roll over any
single component inside it, you
get
that really granular data for
that particular component.
In this case, the size of that
diamond-shaped FAB.
So this is one of many examples
of how the research has made our
products launching here at I/O
better.
Another one is the material I/O
home page. In the same research
I'm talking about, we also got
feedback on an earlier version
of the home page design.
And we heard from designers
that they really like to get
overview videos of anytime
there's a new evolution of
something so they can get a
quick sense of what's changed.
And we had that.
Turns out, bottom of a really
long page and nobody found it
before they were
able to click on the video.
What we did, the website, that
video is really prominent. So we
made it really easy for you all
to get a quick overview of
what's new in material.
So what I just gone through with
you
is giving you examples of how we
use work flow research to
identify the big problems that
we want to put our time into
solving.
And how product research
improves the product no matter
what stage it's in.
And how we use products that
releasing at I/O, how we use
research to make them better.
And if you want to check out
Gallery, go to material.
io/tools. I'm going to hand it
back to Elizabeth now.
>> ELIZABETH CHURCHILL: Thank
you so much, Sara. Thank you,
everybody.
So just a little bit of a
wrap-up, uh a reminder of the
invitation to visit us in Dome
F. And so, what we've shown you
today is just a flavor of the
ways we're using
traditional methods for research
as well as new Meads to
understand how the components
work for
everyday users in terms of
beauty and esthetics, in terms
of usability, in
terms of sort of usefulness but
also accessibility.
And Sara has shared how
important it is for you to send
us feedback on our products
because we do want to work with
you to make sure that your lives
are easier in this pretty
difficult work
flow process from idea to
product that really works.
Another thing I want to let you
know
is that we know that many of you
don't have research teams. We're
lucky enough to have one.
And so, we think of ourselves as
the research system that aligns
with the design system in the
engineering system.
And we have committed to writing
up some of the methods that
we're using and inventing. And
we'll be sharing that along with
the other guidance and spec.
And sharing how these methods
can help
you understand how our tools
work on your context. As Michael
said very clearly, your context
might be slightly different from
our own. So we will be sharing
more of that with you over the
next year.
And so, finally, I hope you take
away how we're bringing together
design
and development and engineering
and research and how we're
really treating
this as a conversation and a
conversation that needs to be a
rich one. And so with that said,
thank you, again, for your
attention.
Please come and join us in Dome
F.
Tent F, I should say, design
accessibility. And, again, thank
you for your attention. Thank
you for coming.
>>
An overview of cloud IoT core.
>>.
>>
Thank you.
An overview of cloud IoT
>> Hi friends.
Thanks for on this last day
coming to
our talk, an overview of IoT
cloud core.
We are working on engineers.  We
are going to bring Gus on a
little bit but if I want to have
little chat.  First thing I need
to know, who are you?  Who out
there are engineers?  Are the
people that are doing the work,
developers?  Nice.  Most of you.
Do we have any bis managers,
decision makers?  Got a couple
of here.  I'm not going to call
actually call on any of you.
We call that theater of cruelty.
Do we have any data scientists
in the crowd?  Good good.  Just
to make sure we are on the same
page who knows what IoT is?
Mast Most of you.  What about
IoT core?
Just to make me feel better, do
you
know what Google Cloud Platform?
Just raise your hand.  For those
that haven't heard of it yet,
IoT the Internet of Things, I
actually voted for 5TI things
that talk to the Internet.  I
thought it would have been more
indic kative of what it is.  It
is a computer connected to WiFi.
IoT device.  Smartphone IoT
device.
Smart meters connected to your
house.
Raspberry pies microcontrollers.
All of these are IoT device.
In 2015 business insider along
with
Gartner did a study that by
2020, 30 billion connected
devices.  That's the phones and
the computers you can see are a
tiny slice of what we are
talking about here.  So why
aren't we there yet?
Why isn't my world connected and
smart?  They have take time and
money.  So really understand
what the hold up is I want to do
a little brief introduction to
the world of electronics.  Does
anyone know if I say the word
constrained device, does anyone
know what that is?  A
constrained device?  A couple of
people are nodding.  A
constrained device is a tiny
computer.  It has got memory and
processor.
analog.
Because of is everything is on
that single chip because it is
memory,
processing, storage.  Are all
severely limited.  This is the
class of computer we are talking
about.  When we talk about 30
billion connected devices.  Who
remembers floppy disks?
I am not talking about the 3 and
a half inch one.  Five and a
quarter inch.  The really floppy
ones.  I know some of us are old
enough that remember, the dinner
size plate ones.
The five and a quarter inch
floppies
they held 360K of storage ofe
age.
These microcontrollers hold less
than this.
Dwebt have that luxury with
microcontrollers.
We can't swap them in and out.
We need something.
A more power computer.
So since I keep bringing it up,
what is IoT core?
It is a 100% managed service.
This means that you don't have
to stand up anything.  You don't
have to put a service up in a
VM.  We handle all of that for
you in Google.  There is no need
for auto scaling.  All of that
is done by the cloud for you.
IoT core provides a global end
point no matter where you
devices are in the world.
Latency is nearest data center
and back.  That's it.
IoT core has two main pieces.
For IoT core the organization,
inside you create registries.
You can create some o logical
organization to them.  And then
devices yourselves.
The messages from your devices
will
using HDPS or MTP protocol
shutter um in to the cloud.
Messages from IoT core, Pub/Subs
are event stream manager and
from there it is the gateway.
IoT core giveses you access to
the rest of Google Cloud's
platform.
So wrap your head around where
we are
now, I want to go back to to
your little history lesson and
talk about how electronics
evolved.
Your household
stuff, they were all made up of
electronic components.  Things
that would respond to electric
signal strength alone.  The more
powerful the signal the more
it would happen in electrical
components.
The
magtron the microwave, decrease
signal strength and it reduces
the temperature.  Because the --
of the physical relationship of
these components to each other,
as the electrical signal come in
each compon component would
actuate in.  Because of the
relationship to them change was
very difficult.  If you wanted
to change functionality of your
electrical circuit you had to
make physical changes to it.
You had to change your bomb.
The minute you add something to
an
electrical circuit, your
resistance goes haywire.
If you wanted to mass produce
your circuit, this is a problem.
Once you created tooling for
manufacturing lib and circuit,
the mass
producing the same template is
nice and easy.  If you
introduced change you have to
retool.  It is very expensive to
make any kind of change.  Some
of these kinds of circuits we
call them analog circuits still
exist today.  But modern
electronics are a little bit
different.
Modern
electronics are still compose ed
things that work with electrical
signals.  Where signal strength
was what changed
things now we have things called
digital protocols.  It will go
on and off rapidly.  A digital
protocol that is understood by
another piece in the circuit.
This means that we can center
our electronics around this
constrained device, this
microcontroller which is very
good at reading signals but
analog and digital and speaking
in this digital protocol.  The
chip itself can now create
functional change in your
circuit without having to
physically change anything
around it.  It is important
because they are inexpensive.
Until reltively recently these
microcontrollers were pretty
expensive.
I can go out and buy a
microcontroller
with WiFi and Bluetooth for less
than $5.  It is very
inexpensive.
The trade off is that
microcontrollers are still
relatively con strained.  They
don't have a lot of memory, a
lot of storage.  So they need
something else to help them
achieve the capabilities that
they are not able to accomplish
on their own.  So this gives you
kind of a back drop for why we
are at it this tipping point
with electronics where cost and
complexity have arrived where we
can do things at scale.  Being
able to create these cheap
complex circuits with
microcontrollers
allow us to create cheap or
inexpensive complex devices that
are going to connect our world.
What is a smart device?  At the
simplest a smart device is
something that can complete an
objective.  That can do a task
without human intervention.  I
don't need to do anything for
it.  Modern electronics and
availability of
these microcontrollers makes
intelligent
control of these devices
economically feasible.  I am
really harping on economically
feasible and inexpensive, I am.
You a few years ago might not
have been possible because of
cost and complexity is
achievable now.  We have the
tools to create these ecosystems
of smart devices.  So smart
devices so we can understand
them there is three basic
approaches to a smart device.
First there is 100% on device.
Everything is contained and done
within your single device.
Something like Google home where
I can use my Voice as input to a
device.
It uses speech-to-text and uses
natural language processing.
And run some kind of task on
device and is it can accomplish
it all without me having to do
anything else.  I have a spoken
word and something happens.  It
might use the Internet to call
out to do something else but
that's part of the task that's
already accomplishing.  The
second, there is edge or border
routing.  Sometimes we call it
the radio protocol approach.
For example, nest has released
something called openthread.
It allows your device to call
out to another neshby device.
So say you have got a device
that can do everything except
Internet but whatever the task
is it needs to be able to call
out to the Internet.  With
openthread it can reach out to
another device that's nearby and
connect
it and borrow its Internet
connection in order to
accomplish its task.  It is
using these other devices to
finish off what it needs to be
done.  And lastly a device can
delegate all of its control to
something else.  A lot of the
time shoos microcontrollers do
that.  They will become a very
dumb but very fast gatherer of
information, gatherer of data
and then hand off all of that
I/O to something else.  A
computer nearby.
Fermata that's the perfect
example of what this is.  You
can delegate all the information
that you gather on one device to
a computer.  So something else
nearby.  So what if I told you
that the computer that we are
connecting to that is doing all
this power for us didn't have to
be anywhere near the devices and
that's where we are -- that's
where we are back to IoT core.
You can start to think about
that.
Like the concept of Fermata IoT
core connects your device to the
cloud.
It expands the capabilities of
this little device.  It gives
you new capabilities without
adding any complexity.  You
don't need more local hardware.
You don't need anything local.
All you need to do is talk to
the cloud.
So all of this so far, history
and electronics is to hammer
this point home
where we are in a world where
kre ated creating device that
talk to the Internet.  I have
touched on why the cloud is
integral to IoT.  I want to show
you a couple of things to make
sure you understand.  This graph
is all of the oil and gas fields
in the Gulf of Mexico.  A little
over 1300 of them.  Each of
these gas fields could have
potentially thousands of sensors
all streaming data to keep our
math similar tell. ple.  Say it
is just a thousand.  Each of
these sensors is only streaming
100 bytes a second.  Nothing.
100 bytes a second.
Even if that's true that's 137
megabytes a second.
Just over eight gigabytes a
minute.
11 and a half tera bytes a day.
You could manage that if you
want.  There a reason that the
cloud was created.
It offloads all of the
infrastructure.  You don't have
to worry about backups.
Don't have to worry about IT
peep toople to run your
machines.  I want to talk about
security.
Some of you may have heard about
it.
A couple of years ago there was
a Botnet attack.
A bunch of routers were ataked
and
took down huge swaths of the
Internet and a temperature
sensor in a fish tank.  A
temperature sensor in a fish
tank in
a casino was compromised.  Pull
out all of the personal
information of the casino's high
rolors that didn't happen to be
secured.  So security is
massively important.  If you are
doing IoT you need to think
about security.
IoT core registers all of your
devices and does all your
encrypted communication through
TLS.1 or later to ensure that
your devices are secure when
they are talking to the cloud.
So we understand why IoT core is
awesome but what else.
IoT core is this gateway in to
the Google Cloud platform.  What
does the platform have for IoT?
This is a small sampling of what
the Google Cloud platform has
for you.
Just keep scrolling and keep
scrolling.  There is enough
products on that we don't bhoe
what all the products do.  They
are all specialized.  A ton of
products that will fit any need
that you want.  So first we have
got our devices.
Bringing their data up in to
GCP.
These payloads the messages and
brokered as events in to Cloud
Pub/Sub are event stream
manager.  From there once it is
in Pub/Sub we have some products
that can respond to
our inn incoming messages.
They exist in the serverless
space that you can call with an
end point or
they can respond to events
within GCP.
In our case the Pub/Sub message
coming in will trigger a cloud
function to run on T. The it.
DataFlow is our managed service
to handle transforming incoming
streams.
So again like cloud IoT core it
will scale without having you to
do anything.  It will scale to
handle it.
It be used to do things like
filter incoming data if there is
only some data that you want to
make in to final storage or
massage data in to a specific
format if you need it to be
processed in specific way.  It
acts as pipeline for data.
Cloud Pub/Sub is temporary.  If
you don't do something with them
they go away.  So a product like
DataFlow can shuttle your data
in to the other products which
brings us to our storage and
Analytics section.
There is way more than are shown
here.  These three are a small
sampling.  We have a big table.
Big table is our know SQL
database option.  Again managed
service.  It will scale with
however much data you put in it.
BigQuery is our enterprise level
data warehousing.
You can query your pe that bytes
data with SQL statements.  Don't
have to learn a new system.
They can use SQL to find
insights in data.  Not learning
a new system and finally we have
got machine learning.
TensorFlow is the open source
software allows you to train
your models and cloud machine
learning engine is hosted
TensorFlow.
Harness all power of Google's
backbone to train and run on
your models fast ar and
efficiently.  We have tools that
can visualize your data.
We have cloud
data lab and we have got out of
box data studio.  However you
want to visualize it.
So for IoTed IoT would all of
these together you can perform
device management and monitor
health.
You can and lice truly absurd
amount of data and you can
perform things like predictive
maintenance in manufacture can
and utilities using tools like
machine learning.
Cloud IoT core provides that
gateway, it provides the device
management and connectivity for
all of your devices in to the
rest of Google Cloud platform.
It has been only a year.  Last
year I/O is when we announced
cloud IoT core.  So I want to
take a sec just to highlight
what we have done since then.
First when we announced that
beta a year ago it could only
talk MQTT.  If you didn't have a
device that could do MQTT you
are out of luck.  We added https
since then.  A broader range of
devices can connect to IoT core
and have their data managed.  A
year ago when we launched each
registry, those buckets of
devices mapped one to one to our
-- to Pub/Sub.  So any device
data that was coming in to your
registry would only go in to a
single bucket of Pub/Sub and we
have added the ability to map
multiple Pub/Sub topics.  So you
can shard your data that way and
organize it.  We have added
Stackdriver logging so that you
can monitor your health through
Stackdriver which is -- that's a
logging and monitoring tool that
we have got I forgot to mention
it before.
And brand new and I don't think
that anyone has announced it.
Android things.  I am sure you
have all heard a lot about
Android things across this
conference.
Android things has created a
plug-in that releasing next week
that will allow
you to connect Android devices
to core.  Alls of cool stuff you
can create using it now let that
kind of percolate in the back of
your mind what more can you do
with it.  If it is connected to
the cloud what else can you do.
What global reach can you
accomplish.  Now that I have
talked your ear off
oim I'm going to bring Gus back
up and he is going to show you
in practice some of the stuff
that I have been talking about.
>> GABE WEISS: Let's have a
wonderful round of applause for
Gabe.
(Applause.)
>> GABE WEISS: I will be the
Yen to his yang.  So this is
actually the -- this is the
third time that I have bifren --
that I am showing the nuts and
bolts of how cloud IoT core
works and kind of this -- this
is I/O right now and I remember
a year ago the cloud IoT core
team came in
front of you all and
demonstrated the product for the
first time.
And when they did it, I have no
idea how they were able to get
such a robust and beautiful demo
at that point in time.  Because
there was a lot of pieces that
the experience was a cliff.  The
first time that I show -- the
first time I showed this demo
the -- it blew up in my face and
that was for couple of reasons.
One of them was we didn't have
the --
we didn't have the cloud console
features for IoT core.
There was no, I have
visual way of adding devices.
So I had to write sample that
would
make API calls with the device
I.D. and project I.D.
all of these values that are
really easy to fat finger.
So within general availability,
the
Google Cloud SDK or G cloud for
those -- for those who don't
know Google Cloud is
command line utility that's writ
and allows to do all the things
in cloud programmatically from
the command line and it works --
it works really well from cloud
resources and if you go and
do the Codelab I actually how
you do is
a lot of cloud resource manage
ment using the G cloud SDK.
I am going to show you how to do
the
nuts and bolts of cloud IT core.
In some sort of sample app.  I
will unlock my machine.
And we'll switch to computer.
Could everyone see that?  Good?
Bigger, smaller?  Awesome.
So if you remember, the entry
point in
to cloud IoT core is Google
Cloud Pub/Sub.
And so before we can receive
messages and transmit -- before
we can transmit messages and
then process those messages
from Pub/Sub we have to create a
Google Cloud Pub/Sub topic.
So I'm going to create a Google
Cloud
Pub/Sub topic
.  I'm super nervous.
So I type really bad.  It is
easier when they talk.
So I decided in G Cloud Pub/Sub
topics
create IoT 2018 top -- for topic
and so
now I to G Cloud Pub/Sub
subscriptions.
So the subscriptions will, of
course,
my -- Pub/Sub and I forget the
-- all right.
So when you create the
subscription you have to
associate that subscription with
a topic.
And then I have to add create,
and if you see me struggling up
here know how
to fix what I am doing ing don't
hesitate to yell out.  Topic.
All right.
So now I have created a Google
Cloud
Pub/Sub subscription that is
associated
with the Google Cloud Pub/Sub
topic.
Whenever I publish messages in
to that topic they get queued up
in to the subscription.
And I can pull them from the sub
description.
I am going to create a Google
Cloud
IoT core registry
.  And I'm not the best typor
and talker.  And so associated
with this registry is going to
be an event notification
configuration.
And so what that just means is
when
messages are sent -- telemetry
which could be something like
sensor data from a device.  This
is the topic Windows
notifications can go to.  And so
you can also set this to so that
you can have notifications going
to other types of things and we
-- the
future may offer other ways of
connecting with cloud.
So now I created a registry.
And after -- now that -- so the
registry will contain devices
that
represent the identity of these
-- of your smart devices or IoT
-- Internet connected devices
and so now I'm ready to add a
device.
So the device connects using an
asynchronous encrypted
credential.  So you give us your
public key and then you encrypt
your data with your private key
when you authorize and you
get JSON web token.  So what
this is going to do is invoke
a couple of -- I can never type
those open commands correctly.
All this is doing is calling
this open SSL command which will
generate a
public/private key pair with job
compatible algorithms.
Now that I have my device keys I
can
-- I can register a new device
and I'm going to call E2E
because that's the device that I
recommend using for the end to
end example.  And if you want to
follow on your own through a
step by step example.  You can
find this in the documentation
at cloud.Google.com/IoT.
When I create this device, I am
going
to use the -- I am going to use
the EC key that was created with
open SSL then
I get at the ES256 string
representing the type, the
sliding type that's
correctly named for JWT.  And
after this comes back, then we
are
ready to connect to Google Cloud
IoT core.  And so this is going
to use -- for
this example I am going to use
the HTTB example which is the
most basic way of connecting to
Google Cloud IoT core.
So this is just some sample.
And so there is the -- there is
the project I.D. that cloud
resource associated with the
device registry and the Pub/Sub
topic and so forth.  And then
the registry I.D. which is the
container for these devices and
the devices I.D. and everything
else that you saw me put in in
the priest message.  And now
Docker is going to ask me to
update.  I will do that later.
Yeah.  Okay.
So all right so when the --
here's a job that it is
calculated from the device and
because it is a brand-new device
you will see that the
configuration is empty and also
-- yeah.  That's nice.  Nice.
But here -- so here is the
configuration for the device and
you can
see that I have published a
couple of
telemetry messages that are
events representing something
that this device is transmitting
to the cloud.
And so now if I use G cloud
again,
Pub/Sub
and I could do subscriptions
whole, all right.
Forget the name again.
Subscription is 2018 sub.  And
when I do this, I should see the
messages, I should see those
telemetry messages that were
transmitted by the virtual
device to the cloud.  This is
always a scarey part.  There it
is.  So sorry for my -- for how
this looks kind of funky in
here.
You can see attributes for the
metadata and anything else that
you want to push in to your
topic inside of this data field.
All right.  So if you have seen
any of the talks
before on cloud IoT core you see
me do this a lot of different
ways of it is kind of boring.
But these devices -- but this is
it.  You have seen the entire
capabilities of the cloud.
One those messages are in
Pub/Sub you can process those
with all the cloud resources
that Google provides.
This could mean processing image
data
or reaking to some sort of
condition
inside of that image or
warehousing
massive data and able to do
Analytics in realtime with it.
We are going to do something
different today.  I want to show
you this working on a
hardware and so I have brought
with me an Arduino device and
this has sort of been a 20%
project of me.
It is an experimental library.
Arduino is a physical computing
platform and it allows you to do
things
like Blink lik lights.
Modern electronics can easily be
controlled and actuated from the
-- from our Ardino devices.  A
so I'm going to do something --
the virtual devices are really
good for things like load
testing and estimating and like
learning about -- learning about
the product.
And then the our experimental
library with Ardino which I
cannot recommend that you go to
production yet.
As -- it is on my github
account.  And it is also
borrowed.
So thank you Arvao for your
contributions.  And anyone who
is interested in
contributing to our Ardino
project is welcome to.  I am
going to go from useful device
to a physical real world device
that we can
use for -- that we can then use
for prototyping and other things
to get an idea of like when you
have your actual
device built on, you know, one
of the
more robust solutions that our
partners offer.  So in order to
work with Arduino you
can install the library using
the library manager and after
that library is installed inside
of the examples will appear.
Google Cloud IoT core jot and
inside
of here each of these -- is a
sketch, a
n arduino sketch is a way of
specified a
source file and open inside of
the I.D.
Inside of the sketch is config
and
then inside of here are all of
your configuration that we just
did in the
virtual device except as
(inaudible) with this physical
device.
And I'm just going to connect to
a
WiFi
.  And everything else
.  And this is the same
configuration
that I just used from before
.  Oh,.  This.  This.
Sorry.  The project I.D.  Oh,
yes yes.  So the project I.D. is
-- thank you.  Thank you.  Yes.
This is going to save you a lot
of frustration in a minute.  The
cloud resource is associated
with -- with all the things that
you created to top it and then I
am going to do a
transform on the private key
which I am going to use for
creating the connection
credential and this is open SSL
command that I can never
remember.  So now I have taken
that private key and turned it
in to a string that looks a lot
like this string and then going
replace the string with that
string
.  And very soon now when I
click the run, oh.  Thank you.
We are doing a good job, guys.
Okay.
And I make sure I have the right
port.  Okay.
And this is -- we recently -- I
added this port for the boards.
It is the Arduino style boards.
They have a feel to them that's
kind of nice.
So now that I have -- now this
device has connected -- let's
see with my logs here.
Oh, no
.  Something is wrong
.  So then --
let's see
.  Private key is wrong.  Did I
do the public one?  Thank you.
You are the best.
And this should be E
C -- try this again
.  Place it.
Oh, I need to save the sketch
.  Sorry.  Try this again.  Let
me -- sorry, say that again.
>> (Off microphone).
>> GABE WEISS: Oh, yeah.
No.
So Arduino strings do support
this.  Working as expected.
So let's see here though
.  All right.  Sometimes the
time server doesn't return the
right time and that can get
-- oops.  And so if this --
there we go.  So now it is
working.  Yes.  So this is the
experimental library everyone.
And yes, so heed my advice.
(Applause.)
>> GABE WEISS: Yes,. And
that's why -- shouldn't use in
production yet.  But maybe some
day.  So now -- so -- and this
sample with the configuration
message is set to something
other than the value of 1, only
one light will be on on the
board and if I set the
configuration message to 1, so
the configuration for this
device is set to 1 instead of 0
or
hello, then that -- then two
lights on
the board should turn on.  And
let's see.  We'll set it to 1.
And then everyone watch on that
screen.  The light that comes on
is on the left side of the board
I think.
And so we just updated the
device configuration and then
through my blazing fast Internet
connection there it is, yeah.
All right.
(Applause.)
>> GABE WEISS: Okay.
And so this is nice.  Devices
are fun.
And being able to prototype
stuff with Arduno is fantastic.
You are able to do stuff quickly
and
you are able to in just a short
period of time and inexpensively
have an understanding of whether
or not
something will actually work
.
>> GUS CLASS: My mic is on.
Do I need to get close to you?
Can we use -- can we use this
mic?
Attached.
It is going to end poorly.  Do I
need to get really close to you
Gus?
>> GUS CLASS: I will speak
to Gabe and Gabe will speak to
you.
>> GABE WEISS: It is going to
be a great game of telephone.
>> GUS CLASS: Three weeks
ago Gus
needed to do a demo.
>> GABE WEISS: Needed to do
a demo.  To this conference.
Yeah.
>> GUS CLASS: And I had
nothing.
>> GABE WEISS: He had nothing.
So he went to the sound guy who
is sgeting him a new battery.
He had some lights.  Some
project he was working with LE
deshgss.
>> GUS CLASS: And we are back
.  I thought you would be much
more E excited if I show you
robots.  It is a toy like this.
I want to show you under here.
So this toy and this little toy
has -- remember Gabe was talking
about digital systems on and
offs, well, this toy has
something -- I saw this on this
toy.
It has an infrared receiver and
it has this little remote
associated with it
which I have smudged off
anything that will hint at what
it actually is.
But this little toy responds to
a Blinking light on here.  And I
just showed you a Blinking
light.  What if instead of that
little light
these signals, these
configuration
messages that are transmitted to
these devices are interpreted in
to the motion commands for this
little toy and I thought that
was cool.  I started
prototyping.  And on the boards
very similar to that other one I
showed you and I came up with
this.
My friend
Addison added some imperative to
this little guy.  When the
device comes online it should
wiggle a little bit.  And that
way I will know it is connected
to the WiFi.  So there a little
Blinking light that
indicates the various stages of
the boot.
And I'm going to start a flask
app.  There it is.
So when it just -- it nodded its
little head.  What was going on
it is now connected
to -- it is now connected to
WiFi.  It is now connected to
WiFi.
And -- this is not the device.
And now I can go in to my device
registry here again and I can
send configuration messages and
then control this.  And what's
interesting is that no longer
something that's like a device
that's locally here.  This
device could be anywhere.  And
it doesn't really -- and like
the end could be millions of
these devices
and you can do things like
coordinate across those devices.
Let's send a configuration
message to the device that will
cause the device to turn its
head.  When the device responds
to the command it should just
nudge a little bit there.  There
it is.  And so what you will
also notice on
the front of this device I have
added a sonar sensor and that
sonar sensor will
pretty accurately measure
distance up to about 30 meters
away.  I wanted to do something
that shows getting data from
your devices, putting that data
in to the cloud and then
processing that data.  So we
very similar to what we do in
the Codelab.
And so I created that little
flask app and then this little
flask app has this UI that only
developer could love.  But when
I click that button it sends
a configuration message to this
device
if I'm lucky
.  Let's see.
And that configuration message
will trigger this device to
start moving in this sort of
sonar pattern and I mean these
are toys.  So I mean it is not
going to turn
exactly the same amount of
degrees every time but it is
close enough to we can
get a general idea for the
surroundings around this.
And then on the blazing fast
Internet to my computer, it
should render --
that's nice.  Still good.  Still
good.  So then we render -- it
is all right.  You can clap.
So then we render, so a graph
kind of surroundings of this
device.
And so adding -- so adding the
Internet capabilities to this
toy was as easy as just adding a
hat on top of it
and also the -- because of the
low
requirements for the hardware
for cloud
IoT core I am able to build
these hats an at a cost of maybe
$5.  You can imagine in your
factory or your store or in your
office or where --
wherever you have these modern
electronic systems that you can
communicate with with this
Internet connected devices then
you can add
Internet cap inlts to those
devices.  Because they are so
inexpensive it is possible to
produce a large number of
these devices in a relatively
short period of time and then
kind of have some fun with them.
So after -- some time after this
conference I am going to try to
open source this software.  You
can check it out.  And for now
I'm going to do the thing that
everyone wants me to do whenever
I show them the robots and that
is make them move as a swarm
Army.  Okay.
And it is at times like this
that I really appreciate how
little data the cloud IoT core
product sips because I am
totally not using my phone for
connecting these devices.
>> GABE WEISS: Totally is.
>> GUS CLASS: Yes.
All right.
>> GABE WEISS: We should
have a bunch of them online.
>> GUS CLASS: There we go.
Okay.  And it is just about time
for them to
march
.  All right.
And we go back to.  Thank you
Gabe for wrangling all of these
robots.
All right.  Uh-oh.  Look out.
Go robots.  Go.
>> GABE WEISS: WiFi.
>> GUS CLASS: It is probably
the WiFi.  But I mean --
>> GABE WEISS: They are
Blinking really pretty.
>> GUS CLASS: They are
I feel pret pretty good about
that.  There they go.  Thank
you.
(Applause.
)
>> GABE WEISS: We have a
jumper.
>> GUS CLASS: All right.
They have already become
attention.
This one is trying to break
free.
All right
.  Yeah,.  Yes.
I also wanted to do this just to
make Gabe happy.
Let s go back to the slides and
we will wrap up.  Okay.
So going back to -- so going
back to
other approaches to -- to adding
smart and intelligent cap
abilities to your devices.  We
would be -- I want to again say
there is other ways of doing
this than just complete
Delegation to the cloud.
You can use edge border routing
to extend the capabilities of
nearby devices to other devices.
You can use ondevice smarts with
things like Android things.  If
you have all the capabilities
throughout the cloud or some cap
abilities shared with the cloud
Android things is a great way to
do these things.  As Gabe
mentioned at the very beginning
we have strak driver logging and
Stackdriver logging for some
people can get them a lot of
information about
things like security audits and
other -- like combined with
metadata of devices may be
enough for a lot of what
people's IoT needs are.
And because we went a little bit
over
I will try to wrap up quickly
and I will let Gabe close us
out.
>> GABE WEISS: We want to
hear from you.
Go here and enter in our talk,
the
cloud IoT overview.  Thank you
for coming.
(Applause.
)
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Grand ambassadors are assist
with
dregting you through the
designate #d exits.
If you have reg fered for the
next session in this room we ask
that you please clear the room
and return via the registration
line outside.  Thank you.
irecting you through the
designated exits.  If you have
registered for the next session
in this room we ask that you
please clear the room and return
via the registration line
outside.  Thank you.
Add Firebase to your
cross-platform
React/Native over or Flutter
r Flutter app
You
>>
Hi everyone.
I hope you have enjoyed the past
three days and are ready for run
last talk.  My name is Kat.
I'm software engineer on the
Firebase team.
>> KIANA MCNELLIS: And I am
Kiana.
>> KAT FANG: We never have
enough time and we are looking
for new tools to help us build
faster.
We are going to ape
apps that we have built.
>> KIANA MCNELLIS: Over the
past couple of weeks I have been
building this app.  Where you
have a different category each
time and it gives you a couple
of options.  So for this one up
here on the screen we have tech
gadgets.  Maybe we le get an
option between a
phone and laptop that take a
picture and this was written on
Flutter which is
cross platform framework that
uses dart and then compiles down
to native interfaces.
So we can still get featured on
iOS or Android app stores.
>> KAT FANG: Since I come from
a web
background I have built the same
app using React/Native.
Instead of writing in dart I can
use JavaScript.  There are a lot
of different cross platform
apps.  You might have heard --
cross platform frameworks.
You might have heard of an
ionic.  All of these allow you
to develop in one code base but
target multi mel platform the
and we can choose one which we
are most familiar with the
language and the tooling around
it.  So long as we don't need
down to the
metal performance this can gave
us save us lots of time.  Let's
trick out a demo of the app we
have built.
So this is a Flutter app that
Kiana has been building.  We
have this nice tutorial that
tells
us we will be taking picture and
along
the way we will get some
trophies.  Here is our progress
screen.  And let's go ahead and
check out the next level.  Here
we will need to upload a picture
of a hat.  Nice hat.
And this goes to server verifies
its actually hat and tells our
app that we can continue.
And here we have won or first
trophy.
Awesome.
So let's go back to our slides.
>> KIANA MCNELLIS: So I
think we
built a pretty nice, app.  This
is our user base right now.
Me, you and couple of frinds
from our office.  How request we
make our user base look like
this.  With users from all over
the world
engaged in actively using.
Unfortunately right now our user
base is more looking like this.
The people who we have got ton
use it don't have a great
experience and they
are not even getting to the
second level.  So how do we
increase our user engagement?
We have tried adding some adds
and I have done some sharing
with friends but what's next.
>> KAT FANG: This is where
Firebase can help us.  It is
cross platform.  So it is a good
fit.
Flutter react native.
Effective did Firebase provides
tools and services that our apps
can connect to.  Giving us the
power we would normally get.  To
do this we have used
integrations that already exist.
To integrate Firebase with
Flutter we
are using the Flutterfire plug
in and we
use the react native Firebase
module.
Which can help us understand our
users, discover issues and tweak
it so that our users will love
our app.  So let' goes back to
the issue that Kiana mentioned.
We have lots of people giving
up, not a whole lot of usage.
People are leaving us back
reviews.  It is not great.
It turns out 50% of all issues
that people leave bad reviews
for are due to things like the
app crashing or hanging,
due to network issues, or heavy
resource usage.  These are all
errors that we as developers can
fix and should fix.  When I see
it in my own app locally I can
debug it easily.  Even if I know
these issues exist in the wild,
sometimes it can be hard to find
them because I can't reproduce
them locally.
Foo Firebase allows us to add
observibility.
It gives us me metrics such as
refr knew.  And versions of app
are being used by people but to
gain specific insights we
can add custom Analytics and
this allows us to track things
what level are people
reaching, which are easiest
options.  With performance
monitoring I'll be able to
measure latency.  Out the door
we get traces for things like
app start and network requests.
But we can add custom trace to
get fine grained measurements of
latency.
With crashlytics we will get a
report every single time a crash
happens in the wild and this is
useful for finding these issues
that people are not reporting to
us.  We drop it in and we will
get the line of code that the
crash happened on.  With cross
platform apps we will have to
capture the crashes ourselves
but
then we can use kuscustom
logging.  And -- while
crashlytics is only available on
react native module right now.
However if you like what you see
and you are using Flutter, all
of these are open source
repositories.
So feel free to contribute
.  To streamline our demo we
have done a little bit of setup.
Kwef have created our project
Firehunt and in our project we
have created apps
for each of our iOS
and Android.  React native and
Flutter.  We have been dropped
in the modules we will want to
use for Firebase.
Here we are using Firebase core
for Analytics performance for
performance
monitoring and crashlytics needs
fabric.
For Android we will be doing
something similar and we have
done a little more
setup with crashlytics which you
can read the documentation for
here.  So set up a lot of the
way let's jump to our actual
demo.  What do we get as soon as
we have set this up.
We will get an overview with
Analytics for our apps.  But it
looks like none of our apps have
very many users.  The numbers
aren't going to be so
interesting.
So let's go take a sneak peak at
Bingo Blast which is an app that
has been out in the wild a
little bit longer many of we
have our daily users in green.
Our weekly users in purple and
our
monthly users in blue and we can
scroll down to get other metrics
as well.
How much revenue the app is
making and what versions of the
app people are using and we
scroll down to the bottom we can
see where in the world people
are using our app from.  So in
this case a lot of people are
playing Bingo Blast in the U.S.
but also all around the world.
We can also take a look at the
events tab.  And this shows us
the user events that are tracked
in our app.  We get a bunch of
these for free such as app
installs or app removals and
session stars but this is also
where we
will be able to add -- where we
will be able to see our custom
Analytics events.  If we check
ought our audience this is is
where we can segment our user
base and target different
Firebase features to different
segments later on.  Here we have
grouped things by purchasers and
even purchasers by locality.  So
we can have features which are
targeted specifically to say
people in Australia.
All right.  Let's actually
get a look at what adding a
custom Analytics event looks
like in code.
Here we are using react
anywaytive native.  The first
thing we will need to do is
import our Firebase module.  And
here we have the image picker
screen.  This is the screen
which allows you to
pick a imn image and receives
the verification from the
server.  If we have the right
image it will call complete
level and if we have the wrong
image it will call wrong image.
We want to add a custom
Analytics event when someone
completes the level.  Let's go
ahead and do that.  Here we have
given the name of our Analytics
event to be level, the number
about this level is reached.
And we are calling Firebase.
Analytics.
logevent to doing that to the
server.
Let's go ahead and run our app.
Skip the tutorial since we know
what we are doing.  Look for
cookie.  We will use this
picture of a cookie
that we took before
.  Submit to that to be
verified.  And it looks like our
verification worked and we won a
trophy.  Awesome.  So now let's
take a look in the console.
We can see that these custom
Analytics events are coming
through in the debug view
.  And this will give us a good
idea of how our Analytics will
be coming in as we add them to
our app.  So here we can see we
have a bunch of
screen views, a bunch clicks
user engagement and we have seen
that level 3 has in fact, been
reached.  So while we are still
in the console
let's take a look at what we get
from performance monitoring out
the gate.  I have added no
custom code.
The only thing I did was add the
cocopod to my iOS version and we
can already see the sorts of
traces we can get.
I have got no major issues but I
do have a minor issue with app
start.
It is taking almost 600
milliseconds.  That's probably a
slow enough start that I give
someone a progress screen it
might turn them off from my app.
We can take a look at the
network requests.  And from this
we can see that all of our
requests are network requests
are in fact, successful but
there is this one here which is
taking two seconds.  That's kind
of slow.
Let's dig in to it.  This is the
end point that verifies our
image.  And it is probably slow
because we
have to upload a large image on
occasion.
So maybe an optimization we can
make
is making our image smaller or
somehow speeding up our machine
learning algorithm on the back
end.
That is a problem for my Backend
self tomorrow or the day
afterwards.  So what about
crashlytics?  That was a good
overview.  Let' goes back to the
code and see how we can add
crashlytics to pick up the
crashes that are happening of if
we see
our app and check ot the
trophies tab we will see that
there is a crash.
This was reported to me by Kiana
thanksfully a couple of hours
ago and we can use this to see
how crashlytics works.  So again
we are in our trophy screen.
The first thing we are going to
do is
import Firebase.  And when we
get an error we will use the
global handler to capture it.
And log in to crashlytics.  Here
we will grab the stack trace,
log that, and record the error.
So now if we run it, we will be
able
to capture the crashes.  Yep and
that's just not working.
So let gaes to the console and
see
what that actually produced.
We can go in to our first issue
here.  And our stack trace here
looks like a
whole bunch of native mumbo
jumbo.
We can take a look at the logs
and we can see that this was due
to
actually let's go to the
previous stack trace.  Stack
trace which tells us in our
trophy screen we have typed in
rendered trophs.  It looks like
a typo to me.
Let's go ahead and fix that.
All right.  We will just add
two more letters.
Run our app again
.  And now we will actually be
able to
see the trophies that we have
rightfully earned.  So now that
we fixed all of the issues in
our app what else can we do?
>> KIANA MCNELLIS: If we go
back to the slides, the next
step in what we
want to do is try to start
experimenting
with our user base by adding
Cloud Messaging, why can start
experimenting with different
engagement strategies and run
tests and then we will be able
to
see what's working using the
anaAnalytics we just added.
First step is with Firebase.
It works across iOS and Android.
We can send a push notification
to all our users.  We can
actually take that notification
put it in it to your app and
then run
some custom code to do an
interaction based off of that.
We can even target our messages
based
off things like locale and peep
people's experience with our
app.  We have our Firebase
console send a
notification and you can run
your own API server.  Then once
it is at our Cloud Messaging it
will send a notification ought
to all of oush users who have
registered notification tokens
with Firebase.  So let's switch
back to the code and see how it
works.
So here we have our Flutter pub
spectra and we are adding our
Firebase messaging plug in.  And
then we run packages get and it
gets our new values of
Then we are going to go ahead
and this is our main content
screen and we
are just going to import our new
package.  And, of course, it hit
it because dart is pretty
awesome.  And then in our
content state we are
going to just go ahead and
create that variable.
And then initialize it
.  So in here you can see that
we request a notification
permission than is for iOS.  It
will pop up a question to our
users asking hey do you want to
enable messages and it is one of
those requires things that iOS
makes you do.  You can see that
we get the token here and if you
save that to your database you
can actually target that
specific user for a custom
notification later.
Then we are going to add some
extra configuration code and
this will allow us to handle the
notification right in our app.
The first two on launch and on
resume if our user hits the
notification and we are not
currently in the app, it will
send that data on to us and then
we will do things like
navigating to the right page.
However if we are already in the
app
we want to alert the user of
that notification because the
system is not going to handle
automatically.  So we go ahead
and show the alert and then
handle that code.  So the final
thing we want to could is
go over to our Android manifest,
and we are going to register a
custom and hint handler so we
make sure that Flutter sends
that notification right to our
app.  Cool.  Let's run that.
And while it is running let's go
ahead to our console and we will
go down to our cloud messages
tab and here we can create a new
notification.
Let's do something like check
out our new levels.  Give it a
label and target our Android
users for this one.
And then hit send.
And then back in our Android
app.
>> KAT FANG: Do we want to add
advanced option?
>> KIANA MCNELLIS: We. Extra
notification stuff.  We are
going to add some custom fields.
The first is some text for our
inapp notification.  And then
the location we want to go which
is the progress screen.  And
then our special intent handler
for Android.  Cool.  Now we will
go back and send the app.
And go over to our Android.  And
in the notification center there
we should have an app pop up.
Yeah, it stopped running.
Sorry.
Just send that again
.  Just resend that
notification.
>> KAT FANG: Sure.
>> KIANA MCNELLIS: The cool
thing you can just duplicate it
and send it
right again.
>> KAT FANG: Still looks
good?
>> KIANA MCNELLIS: Yeah,.
Cool.
Let's go back to the app.
>> KAT FANG: I can see it
right here on the podium.
>> KIANA MCNELLIS: And we
already clicked it and it is at
the progress
vein screen.  Nice.  Let's
switch back to the slides.
So Firebase remote config allows
us to try out different features
and tweak our
experiences for different users
and different user groups and
change the UI based on things
like a new feature flag.  How
does it work?
Well, you have a hard coded
option in your app right now.
And it gives the same experience
to everyone.  But we want to
change that.
So with Firebase remote config
we stick in a new variable and
it sections
from the dynamic value for that.
And then it updates your UI
accordingly.  So let's try that
out.
So back in our Pub/Subspec we
are
going to add the remote config
plug in and packages.Git.
Then in our content screen we
are
going to import that package
once again
and create a new variable.  And
then we will go ahead and
initialize.
So this time we are going to
do an
asynchronous call and then using
the wait keyboard we are going
to wait for that response back.
If we do, we will go ahead and
hit --
do a configure settings and this
will
make sure that we set some
default settings.  In this case
we are in a debug mode.
We are going to leave the debug
flag
on and then we have going to set
some sensible defaults that we
already have in our app.  And
then update the app accordingly.
And we call set state here
because that's how dart knows to
up date the UI.
We are going to replace the get
config function so just our app
knows to check remote config
first before we use our default.
Let's run that
.  If we go over to our find
screen, we can see we currently
have two options.  But we want
to change it to three.  Or four
and make it a little bit easier
for our users.
So let's go in to the remote
config dashboard.
And we are going to add our
first parameter which is going
to be find number options and we
will set it up to 4.
And then add the parameter and
the last thing is hit publish to
send it out to your users.  Then
in a couple of seconds it will
reach our app and we will just
restart it to make sure it
fetches those new variables
since in this case we only
wanted to start on startup
because otherwise the experience
would change
while the users are using the
app
.  And it just takes a moment to
load
here
.  Cool.  While this is loading
let's go and add
another thing in our remote
config.  The cool thing is we
can actually add parameters
specifically for certain
versions of our user base.  And
of our app.
So if we define a new condition
say is
iOS, then we apply.
If they are using our iOS app,
and we create the condition.
Then we can add a specific
variable
just for those iOS users, say
only three because our iOS users
are going to have a little bit
harder time finding those items
and then we publish the changes.
And then if we go back to our
app, let's see what that find
screen looks like.
Cool.  And it got to 4.
Unfortunately conference WiFi
took a
little bit time to get there.
Without any code changes we were
able
to update that value
dynamically.  So those were all
manual tasks.
But let's switch back to the
slide to learn about some
automatic ones.
So the smarts, predictions, AD
testing and AB testing for Cloud
Messaging all allow us to add
some machine magic to
automate those tasks we were
doing.
We take Google's cloud ML and
inlt great it right in to our
Analytics data.
And helps predict actions that
are usedor base will take.  We
will churn or spend money or we
can
even have it predict custom
Analytics event.
Are they ever going to reach the
third level.
With AB testing we can go ahead
and automate our tests and
interpret the results
automatically.  So we can run
tests with just a sample of our
users or we can do it just with
the certain audience or one of
those predictionion events.
Then we can see if it made an
impact on the metric we care
about and then roll it out to a
larger population if it works.
So this is what it might
look like.
So half of our user base might
get can you beat our latest
challenge and the
other half get new levels
released and we won't have to
choose which does which.
So let's go back and do a demo
of this.  Cool.
So this is our predictions and
you will see we have pretty high
churn nom because our app again
wasn't very good before.  Now
that our bugs are fixed
hopefully that number will go up
but currently it
is at 37% are predicted to churn
but that's a high risk
tolerance.  We are saying anyone
who could possibly churn we want
to make sure to target them.
But if we switch it to a lower
risk
tolerance we can do the users
that are very sure that are
going to churn or maybe we will
help them do the app, use the
app a little easier.
We can also set up down here a
level 3 reached which is custom
Analytics event
that we then took and asked to
predikdik
and it will take a couple of
days to do
and do that prediction.
So next up let's do an AB test
.  So it take as little while to
load on conference WiFi but we
will create an
experiment for notifications.
And let's do something like
giving
everyone I/O troe trophies of we
will target our iOS users.
And let's do like 100% because
we want
every one of our users to get
this one.  We will add three
variants.  Finish a level for
the first.
Limited edition trophy for the
next.  And then a special trophy
for the third.  And then next.
And our goal here will be
session
start because we want people to
open up our app and start using
it.  Then we hit next.
And go ahead and see an overview
of what our AB test will look
like and then
we start the experiment.  Now
this will take a week or so to
run or two weeks if we did the
experiment with remote config
but we actually
started a
n experiment a week ago that we
can show you guys.  This one was
with Android.
And it looks like variant A1
app.
And if we look down, we can see
what
variant A was and we can see
some of the stats on it.  We can
see the conversion rate was 22%
which is pretty good.  And how
many people actually did that
event.  So nice.  Let's switch
back to the slides.  So what are
some other ways I can use all
these cool features we just
started working with?
>> KAT FANG: That's a good
question.
One way we can use predictions
to give
them booster packs maybe they
are having
a hard time with the different
levels.
We can use this -- we can use
Firebase
features if we want to redesign
our app and see if people enjoy
the redesign and
it will also tell us if people
are experiencing more crashes
with the new redesign in which
case we will roll it back.
But if we do like it we can roll
it all the way to 100%.  We can
also use Firebase when producing
new content.
So I'm sure a lot of you have
had that experience where you
just want your users to download
a new app update so they can get
the new content.  We can roll
the new content in to
existing app uploads -- updates
but hide it behind a remote
config variable and then the day
we want to launch the new
content we don't have to wait
for people to update their app.
We will flip our remote
configure flag and send a push
notification to let everyone
know that there is new content
waiting for them.
So we have taken our two apps
react
native and Flutter and added
Firebase features to them.  This
allows us to observe and analyze
using Firebase Analytics,
crashlytics
and performance monitoring and
discover issues before they
reach everyone.
We can make hypothesis as how we
improve the experience with them
and using predict shuns to
segment users
that might be churning or
spending more
money and we can run experiments
on them.  And messaging.  We
will be able to analyze the
changes
we have made what users like,
and repeat the cycle all over
again.  Now that we have added
Firebase when people all across
the world come to our app they
will have a smooth and enjoyable
experience.  Firebase can
actually go beyond even this and
help us develop our next
features using products such as
Firestore which have realtime
synchronous capabilities
allowing us to build things like
teen games so that
people can work together to
finish skacavenger hunts.  But
this is the last talk here at
I/O.  So I encourage you all to
go to Youtube, check out the
other talks that
have happened here these past
three days and explore the deep
dives on there as well.  We want
to hear from you.
So please check out website and
leave us some feedback.  Again
thank you for coming to our talk
and I hope you have enjoyed I/O.
(Applause.
)